with the main threat of the world now
revealed mass effect no longer has to
tiptoe around it anymore and can
dedicate all its time to fleshing out
the reapers and while that sounds like a
great idea mass effect 2 wouldn't do
that the reapers are still an integral
part of the game and there are some
crucial details about them that we will
learn about in this game but it's so
secret that mass effect 2 put that on
the back burner for the time being the
series is known for its incredible world
building likable characters and main
story but bioware this time around
really decided to double down on those
characters as not only has our
companionless doubled but they were
given various quests involving their own
backstories despite this change however
i liked it in fact to this day mass
effect 2 is still my favorite in the
series because of its focus on the
companions to explain why i think this i
should probably start talking about the
game itself so without further ado let's
get started the beginning of the game
starts with two characters miranda and
the elusive man both of them know of
shepard and agree that having him fight
the geth is not worth his time since the
reapers are the real threat it's
refreshing to finally hear someone agree
with shepard until we realize that these
two belong to cerberus we talked about
them briefly when discussing mass effect
1 as we came across some of their
experiments when traveling the galaxy
afterward a paragraph of text will tell
us that it's been about a month since
the ending of mass effect 1 and that the
official report is that saren and the
gathered the council not the reapers
somehow the evidence has literally
slapped them in the face and they still
continue to deny it thankfully though we
don't have to keep reporting to the
council like in mass effect 1. the
question now though is how do you start
the game
by blowing up the normandy shepherd and
the crew are attacked by some unknown
threat and are forced to evacuate but to
make matters worse shepard couldn't get
an escape pod in time so while most of
the crew managed to make it out alive
shepard did not and he dies that is a
pretty intense way to start a game but
shepard obviously isn't dead or else
this story wouldn't exist but that also
raises various questions as to how a
human was blown out of a ship and
possibly crashed into a planet and
managed to live the answer is space
magic and money well that's the short
version anyway miranda and the elusive
man managed to find shepard's body and
stitch him back together but shepard has
now awoken in the middle of a firefight
as the station he is on is being
attacked so now just minutes after
waking up has to fight to survive again
the story is going pretty fast at this
point so let's dial it back and explain
what's going on one of the first people
we'll meet upon waking up is jacob he's
a soldier for cerberus and will fill in
some of the gaps in our knowledge two
years ago shepard was attacked by a
mysterious ship and killed cerberus
managed to find his body and created
project lazarus where the sole objective
was to bring shepard back to life the
elusive man says that he has taken many
gambles in his life and knows where to
put his money and after realizing that
shepard was the only person that was
able to actually do something about the
reapers he decided that making sure he's
alive was critical to the galaxy's
survival losing shepherd would be one of
the biggest blows to not only humanity
but all life in the galaxy not just
because he's the main character but is
because of what the elusive man said he
was the only one who discovered the
reapers and went against the council to
find out more about them in order to
take them down if someone like that were
to die then the world would be at a
massive disadvantage the fact that
shepard is also a human helps cerberus
as well considering they are human
extremists cerberus first started soon
after the contact wars between the
humans and turians a manifesto was
written after that war that called for a
cerberus to guard against the invasion
the author of this manifesto fell off
the radar along with their work but it
wasn't long before people started using
the name to highlight their misdeeds for
example around the year 2160 terrorists
stole some antimatter and the leader of
the group claimed that their sponsor was
cerberus and for the next decade
cerberus agents were assassinating
politicians sabotaging starships and
conducting experiments on aliens and
humans many in the media call them human
extremists they prefer the term human
survivalist but that was quite a long
time ago it seems that the company has
recently gone under new management as
cerberus has now been stockpiling ships
agents and weapons but under council law
cerberus is still deemed a terrorist
threat the reason they haven't been
caught is mostly due to their command
structure the elusive man has taken
drastic steps to hide his identity and
make sure no one can undermine his
operations despite what many may think
cerberus is still doing human and alien
experiments and even experimenting with
geth and reaper technology the reason
why most of this is unknown is because
each group works in cells for example
project lazarus also called the lazarus
cell is only known to that group so no
one in cerberus is given information on
the other members in cerberus so as not
to corrupt other groups plans so project
lazarus is only known to those within
the project and since miranda is the
leader of this specific cell she's the
only one who can talk to the elusive man
coupled with the fact that cerberus is
filled with private agencies and front
companies it's pretty clear how they
managed to not be caught yet as for how
they acquired shepard's body well after
dying to the collectors a group of
beings we'll talk about in a moment they
ended up contacting the shadow broker in
order to find his body but cerberus
managed to get to them first thanks to
them hiring liara and a man named farron
despite knowing that cerberus were
extremists liar works with them anyway
since they promised that shepard would
be revived if he was given to them this
also brings up a good point what
happened to the crew according to jacob
everyone made it out of the ship alive
except some of the servicemen and
navigator presley this means that all of
our companions managed to make it out of
the ship alive but since they aren't
part of the alliance and only joined
because of shepherd's mission many of
them most likely left before the
destruction of the normandy happened
anyway after escaping the initial
firefight would jacob the two meet with
miranda and take a shuttle out of the
facility shepard then finally gets to
meet with the elusive man himself he
never meets face to face due to the
aforementioned details regarding
cerberus but even if that wasn't the
case i can't blame him look at this view
if i was him i would force everyone to
meet me like this so i can constantly
keep looking at this view shepard
clearly doesn't like working for
cerberus but the elusive man tells him
they have a common goal just different
methods of acquiring it now under normal
circumstances cerberus would likely not
be gathering allies to start a war but
recently the collectors are not only
abducting humans from various colonies
but it's also assumed that they work for
the reapers given that cerberus is all
about the advancement of humanity and
the elusive man in particular wants to
destroy the reapers you can see why he
wants shepard alive and working for them
shepard then asks why the alliance or
the council isn't moving in on these
collectors to which the elusive man
states that all of those decisions
require documents and politics plus
claiming that the threat of the human
colonies is from an ancient life-ending
enemy from thousands of years ago would
not help morale the elusive man and
cerberus do not need to worry about all
that though if he wants people to
investigate a colony or set up a base on
a remote planet it can be done within
the same day this change in the chain of
command is rather interesting and
presents a choice for the player no
matter what happens shepard has to work
for them there's no way to decline but
there are various choices throughout the
game that can benefit them like handing
over a collector base or selling them
geth tech the player is given the choice
to help them but the choice can be very
conflicting cerberus is an extremist
company that only cares about humanity
they claim to care about the reapers and
they do but that's only because humanity
is at risk of becoming extinct as well
if there was some disease that was
spreading that was threatening the lives
of the asari or the turians cerberus
likely wouldn't lose any sleep over it
as he said earlier both the elusive man
and shepherd have the same goals but
different methods so the player is
forced to work with an extremist group
because they can help him defeat the
reapers but you also have to consider
that cerberus saved his life and they
also understand that the reapers are the
real threat unlike the council who
refuses to believe the truth bioware
managed to create a conflict from the
very beginning as cerberus while a bad
company is actually very helpful in
regards to providing info on the reapers
and what their next moves could be
cerberus in this game at least when
discussing things involving shepard is
an in-between kind of company they're
not bad people but they definitely
aren't good either the player will have
to decide how they feel about cerberus
and make judgments based on those
feelings and i think the way they paint
cerberus in this game was very well done
it's pretty easy to consider them
terrorists in mass effect 1 but now that
we're working with them we have to
reconsider our initial decision but
before we make any of those decisions we
need to actually see his claims for
ourself the elusive man then provides
him with a shuttle that will take him to
freedom's progress a recently abducted
human colony so that shepard can see for
himself what's going on this colony is
located in the terminus system which if
you remember was the upper part of the
milky way the majority of the game will
take place here which is why a lot of
the enemies we run into aren't just
normal geth by the time you make it to
freedom's progress you'll notice that
the gameplay has changed quite a bit
geth are no longer the major enemy in
this game and the weapons we carry have
ammunition as opposed to the previous
game which had infinite ammo this change
created some backlash and confusion
amongst the community which led to
bioware making an in-law reason for its
decision in mass effect 3. this decision
is actually a great lesson in game
design in that not everything has to be
explained with lore you might think
considering how much i talk about
stories on this channel that a small
detail like this would be a great idea
but it's not i think this inclusion is
pretty stupid at the end of the day it's
just gameplay the team likely wanted the
game to be more intense so taking away
infinite ammo would force the player to
use new weapons and equipment instead of
the same weapon not everything is going
to make sense in a video game especially
when it involves gameplay including lore
about them is like extra credit no one's
gonna penalize you for doing it but
you'll get bonus points for doing so the
problem is that this isn't explained
until a future game so it's clear
bioware made the lore around the
gameplay rather than the other way
around they likely created the ammo
change first and then thought about a
story explanation later because they
realized that a justification for it
would be necessary at the end of the day
though i don't really care and in terms
of gameplay i do actually prefer the
thermal clips more than overheating but
that's really just down to preference
mass effect 2 also allows the player to
import their character from mass effect
1. so our decisions from the previous
video will be carried over into this one
allowing for a truly unique story
furthermore the game even gives us a
chance to change our class and i just
couldn't help myself i told myself
before this playthrough that i would try
soldier again but i just couldn't do it
i have a soft spot for the vanguard
class and it's mass effect 2 that
created that in the original game you
were given a sniper shotgun assault
rifle and pistol but each class had
different benefits like the vanguard
that excelled in pistols at shotguns
back then you were only able to rank up
those weapons but you could still use
the sniper and assault rifle if you
wanted to mass effect 2 did away with
this system and forces the player to use
specific weapons if you like the classic
feel then the soldier is perfect as you
can access just about every weapon but
the vanguard can no longer use that
assault rifle and sniper rifle anymore i
like this change as it actually sets
each class apart from one another
soldiers get more weapons but no biotic
abilities whereas the vanguard gets
fewer weapons but more biotics and let
me tell you some of these biotics are
insane after dealing with some of the
mechs we'll end up meeting another group
here on freedom's progress and we also
get to see a familiar face toddley zora
is still alive and is with a group of
other quarians looking for their friend
vitor vitor is another quarian who came
here as a part of his pilgrimage he
wanted to help out a small settlement
and decided that freedom's progress
could use his assistance that's of
course until the collectors came and
decided to abduct the people of
freedom's progress so now they're trying
to make sure vitor is still alive
stopping us from reaching vitor is a
giant mech and this also highlights
another change in the game's combat
system not only do enemies have more
layers of health but the layers are
different now enemies in mass effect 1
had health and the occasional shield but
this recent entry adds barriers and
armor to the mix as well at face value
they aren't too different but the values
of damage can change depending on the
weapon ammo type and layer of health
this also adds numerous layers of depth
to the companions as various companions
can equip different ammo types like
disruptor rounds for shields and armor
piercing for armor and various biotic
abilities won't be able to work if
specific layers are the current health
bar such as incinerate which is only
effective against health so if the enemy
has an armor or shield up first you're
not allowed to use it after the defeat
of the mech we can meet with vitor and
once again we have another change but
this time it's in dialogue which is the
interop system in mass effect 1 paragon
and renegade were only acquired through
dialogue choices but now you can gain
these points using interrupts as well
many of these are as you would expect
paragon choices are used for stopping
people from shooting someone or saving
someone's life whereas renegade usually
involves taking someone's life this was
a nice addition to the karma system as
many players likely pick choices based
on a predetermined idea of how they
wanted to play the game rather than the
context of the situation in fact that's
actually the exact reason why andromeda
would remove this entirely the
interrupts were a nice way to change
this as you have to actively be paying
attention to the game to find them and
not every interaction will have one plus
you might just be choosing to go against
your paragon or renegade if one choice
is better than the other such as in this
example where i'm playing as a paragon
playthrough but deem this renegade
action necessary since this krogan was
[ __ ] talking me and my crew personally i
prefer the renegade actions the most as
they vary depending on the situation
most of the paragon choices you can
pretty much see coming like this woman
who was crying because she lost her
daughter and the paragon interrupts he's
shepard consoling her and letting her
know that her daughter's killer will be
dealt with the renegade options allow
for more variety like with this reporter
who is annoying shepard and instead of
just talking her down and causing a
scene like i thought she would shepherd
just completely folds her
sacrificing i've had enough of your
disingenuous assertions
regardless i think giving the player
more opportunities to be like their
character is wonderful and these
interrupts are a great way to do that
getting back to vitor he explains that
he was hiding here because he was trying
to get away from the monsters and swarms
those monsters he's talking about are
the collectors a species of beings
beyond the omega 4 relay we know that
mass effect has various mass relays
throughout the galaxy while the omega 4
relay is similar in function but where
it varies is the destination no one
knows where the omega 4 relay actually
goes no one wants to find out and anyone
that has tried hasn't come back the only
group that has been able to make it back
and forth is the collectors but the
collectors themselves are seen as myths
barely anybody has seen a collector
before and anyone who has pretty much
ends up like anyone in freedom's
progress but you may have noticed from
the footage that no blood or signs of
combat were shown so how is that
possible well the collectors use
something called seeker swarms which are
these little bugs that when touched
frees the person in place allowing them
to be taken and kidnapped this also
means that they can clean up all
evidence related to them since all they
do is release the swarm and then once
everyone is frozen the collectors come
in and pick up the bodies making it look
like the colony just up and left one day
vitor somehow managed to hide and not
get caught by the collectors while also
managing to record data on them miranda
says that we need to bring the quarium
back to cerberus before tally jumps in
and says that vitro belongs to the fleet
according to tali service was
responsible for attacking one of the
ships on the migrant fleet which is why
she hates cerberus sadly we never hear
more about this in-game but according to
some of my research the book mass effect
ascension corroborates tally's story
even if she was lying giving vitor to
cerberus really doesn't make that much
sense considering their pro-human
extremism we'll see the outcome of this
decision later so we'll circle back to
this we give visual to tali and then are
told to report to the elusive man after
what we saw at freedom's progress it's
clear that the collectors are behind the
abductions which confirms his suspicions
the only thing he's unsure of though is
if the collectors are working for the
reapers or just merely another threat he
hypothesizes that since the omega 4
relay is still unmapped with only the
collectors being able to use it without
any complications he thinks that the
relay reacts differently to collector's
ships allowing them safe passage he also
believes that if they are working for
the reapers then that would make sense
why they've only been targeting human
colonies since shepherd and the reapers
have some unresolved beef thanks to
sovereign the elusive man also offers up
a really good question why are the
collectors abducting people at all if
the secret swarms can paralyze people
then they can kill them but they're
deliberately kidnapping the colonists
which means there is a reason why the
elusive men says that if they're working
for the reapers then we need to take the
fight to them but shepard can't do it
alone and he'll need a team thankfully
cerberus has taken the liberty of
finding specific members for our team
and these 12 individuals become our 12
companions each of them provides
something meaningful to the team whether
that's knowledge technology or just raw
strength but only do we need a team we
need a ship thankfully not only is joker
back as our pilot but service went
through the hassle of recreating the
normandy with a few new upgrades the
normandy is just as iconic as the
characters so it's only right that the
normandy comes back many of the upgrades
are pretty unimportant like more speed
better armor etc etc what's actually
important though is the new captain's
quarters for shepard to relax in and the
ship's new artificial intelligence edie
the key detail is ai not vi the guys
like avina back on the citadel have no
mind or consciousness they're just a
computer ai's our self-aware computing
systems capable of making independent
decisions ai is seen as technically
illegal within council space and that's
due to the potential creation of rogue
ai and we only need to look at the geth
as a reason why e though despite being
an ai has lots of functions disabled
shepard can ask her how cerberus managed
to replicate the best ship in the
alliance navy without anyone knowing to
which edie says that she has a block
preventing her from answering that she
says that while she has more freedom
than most ai do she still can't reveal
things that go beyond a certain
classification level this is due to how
ai are created they need something
called a blue box which is filled with
adaptive code instead of quantum
computer an ai without a blue box would
be just a bunch of data files but to
make sure the ai doesn't overstep its
boundaries they're given restrictions as
to what it can do and also make sure the
physical hardware is separate from its
software after our introduction with
edie we're allowed to roam the ship and
speak with some of the crew this version
of the normandy feels a lot more
realistic than the previous game as more
the crew can be spoken to now obviously
we can't talk to everybody but we can
talk to our secretary and even the cook
the game also allows us to do things for
our crew like getting the cook more
provisions and getting dr shockwest the
bottle of brandy she lost on the
previous normandy none of these actually
change much minus some different
dialogue but it's nice to be able to
help out the crew and make them feel
like they're a part of the team once the
crew has been talked to and the rooms
have been checked shepard is now given a
chance to choose which team member to go
after first ensure the game completely
opens up we have a total of 12
companions in the game since we already
have two of them that means we have 10
recruitment missions but each companion
also has a loyalty mission so that's 12
more missions but there are also
collector's missions that we have to do
in between these missions to make
matters worse none of them are done in
proper order so you'll likely have to
jump between recruiting new crew members
while also making others loyal and then
to a collector's mission right after
it's extremely disorganized and that's
completely fine when playing the game
but making a video about it not so much
so firstly we'll cover some of the
collector's missions this should give
you a good understanding of why they're
so important to the game we'll cover all
of them up until the final mission in
the game afterward we'll then double
back and talk about all the companions
recruitment and loyalty missions then go
into some side content and dlc before
finishing up with the finale it should
be easier this way especially for those
who haven't played the game before as
instead of this we would just have to
talk about the companions then have to
bring all of them up again like 20
minutes later and just hope you
remembered them so
let's start with the collector's
missions
after recruiting a good chunk of the
crew we were given information on a new
colony being hit by the collectors
called horizon shepard is tasked with
going there and finding more information
on the collectors but the team has to be
careful thanks to the seekers forms
thankfully before this mission one of
our crew members morton managed to
develop a shield of sorts that'll make
us invisible to the seekers forms
allowing us to go in during the
collector's collections the elusive man
also says that ashley williams is
stationed here on horizon keep in mind
though instead of ashley kaden will be
here assuming you picked him back in
mass effect 1. before we arrive on
horizon we get a brief cutscene showing
how the seeker swarms work and we can
see that they do indeed paralyze people
upon being touched we also get a brief
look at harbinger who apparently can
directly control a specific collector at
will upon arriving on horizon we can see
that the collectors also have husks this
is odd because up until now it was
assumed that it was geth technology but
there's no geth on horizon it's learned
a little bit later that these spikes
called dragon teeth are actually reaper
technology that was given to the geth
but now that the collectors have it it
confirms our suspicions that the
collectors do indeed work for the
reapers this was also technically teased
earlier when we saw harbinger the
dialogue implies that harbinger is this
collector leader it's actually just a
normal collector and nothing else
harbinger is actually a reaper who can
assume direct control of any collector
it chooses further confirming the two
group's allegiances shepard will
eventually come in contact with the
collector ship and it uses its anti-air
gun station on the colony to take it
down but it manages to get away before
any real damage was actually dealt after
the big fight shepard will meet ashley
or cayden and it's here where you can
recognize some of the negatives
regarding the dialogue since ashley and
kaden fill the same role they pretty
much get the same dialogue options it's
understandable but it does feel
disappointing because before vermeire
they were unique people but now they're
just the same person after our talk with
ashley arkhaden we can report to the
elusive man and it's here where we can
see why the elusive men shouldn't be
trusted ashley told us that the alliance
got a tip that shepard was alive in
working with cerberus that was because
the elusive man let that info slip out
into the public on purpose the elusive
man did this in hopes that the
collectors would follow the trail so
that we could catch them while they're
attacking just like what we did with
horizon it also confirmed his other
suspicion and is that the collectors
were purposely trying to find shepard
since they work for the reapers but we
didn't even need the elusive man to tell
us this information because harbinger
when controlling a collector will
actually call out shepherd's name
one shepherd acquires more members for
the team the elusive man will summon him
again and this time he has managed to
stumble upon something big there was a
distress call from a taurian patrol that
managed to get attacked by a collector's
ship but not before crippling it
severely this means that there is a
dormant collector ship in the middle of
space without anyone nearby to salvage
it due to the urgency of the situation
it makes sense that we get there as soon
as possible even though technically we
don't have a choice one thing mass
effect 2 does really well is urgency the
missions regarding the recruitment of
our team can be done on our terms but
when the elusive man has a mission for
us we're forced to take it if you try to
use the galaxy map you're then told to
go meet with him instead i like this
sense of urgency because these events
are important and they need to be dealt
with so having the player do them right
now is a nice way of doing so on the
collector ship we find piles of dead
bodies and they are all human the team
assumes that they use them as test
subjects and they likely failed any
tests that they put them through a
little further though is where the most
important piece of lore regarding the
collectors is found in this testing
chamber is a collector so the collectors
were trying to experiment on themselves
according to edie they were running
genetic comparisons between their
species and humanity we don't know why
they were doing this but we do discover
something from the data and is that the
collectors have the same genetic pattern
as the protheans this would mean that
the collectors are modified protheans so
the reapers didn't wipe out the
protheans or at least all of them we
know from mass effect 1 thanks to the
keepers that the reapers are known to
not always kill the species but change
them in order to further their goals the
reapers did this with the protheans but
turn them into what we call collectors
we'll learn more a bit about this in
mass effect 3 but it's important to
understand that the protheans don't look
like this originally the genetic code
was changed thanks to the reapers
modifying their genes presumably for
combat purposes after this we can take a
good look at the billions of pods inside
the ship each one is planned to house a
human in them so this means the
collectors are planning on taking out
all the humans in the galaxy maybe even
all life afterwards since this is just
one ship shepard makes it further into
the base and realizes that they've been
set up and are ambushed the crew manages
to make it out okay but edie reveals
something about the distress signal she
reveals that not only was the distress
beacon made by the collectors and not
turians but the elusive man knew this
and decided to go anyway so he sent
shepard and the crew into a trap on
purpose the elusive man when questioned
about this confirms that he knew this
was a trap he believed that if shepherd
knew he would have likely not taken the
mission this is what i talked about
before when i brought up the elusive man
earlier he's willing to send shepard
into a trap without him knowing so he's
clearly a bad guy but he does get the
results he wants and the mission wasn't
a failure as they did find data that can
give them an opportunity to find the
collector home world remember same goal
different methods he's like saren an
ends justify the means kind of person
and that makes him hard to trust but you
can't deny that he's good at what he
does and his methods do succeed as
dangerous as they are you also have to
consider that you are working with him
so even though you may not be on good
terms with him you and the elusive man
must work together in order to take down
the collectors it's hard to like and
dislike him which was the same conflict
i had with sarri the only difference is
that you're actually working with the
elusive man so the situation is a little
bit different just like saren i found
the elusive man extremely well written
especially because he's not the
antagonist of this game saren did bad
things because he's also the game's bad
guy the elusive man is a teammate and
yet he's still making questionable
decisions which is why it's hard to
decide whether or not you should
actually trust him from the data we
gathered on the ship we discovered that
the collectors and reapers use an iff or
an identify friendfo system that allow
ships with it to make safe passage into
the omega 4 relay this is why no one has
been able to find the collector
homeworld because they don't have the
iff apparently the elusive man knows of
an alliance science team that found
something called the great rift this was
originally just a crater but then they
discovered that the crater was created
by a giant accelerator weapon by
following the flight path he discovered
that the target for the weapon was a
derelict reaper he assumes that the
reaper should have an iff on it which we
will need now it's probably clear by now
that the elusive man is being used as a
device for the writers to pull stuff out
of their ass in order to make the plot
make sense it's not great but that's
pretty much science fiction in a
nutshell random things you've never
heard about are just revealed as if it's
normal and while the characters might
think it's normal to the viewer it's
definitely not it's not a terrible
method of storytelling by any means but
oftentimes you'll hear something about a
character and then you'll think how is
that even possible this iff though is
the one collector mission that we aren't
required to do right away activating
this mission is like passing the point
of no return and it's also where we get
our final companion so i'll save this
mission for later when we get to them
since this mission starts the finale
shepard is allowed to do this when they
deem it necessary so let's go back and
get acquainted with our crew before we
head out we're not only going to be
looking at the recruitment and loyalty
missions but also see if their reasons
for joining shepard are valid to make
sure they weren't shoehorned into the
story the first two members of the crew
we should probably talk about are zain
and kasumi these two were released later
in the game as dlc and as such their
mission structure is a lot different
than the rest of the crew the regular
way to do these missions is to find
their locations from the dossier recruit
them and then after some time you'll be
given a loyalty mission for zayn and
kasumi though their recruitment missions
are done and over within about two
minutes and they can't actually be
talked to all you can do is press the a
button on them while they say some
dialogue in the room is also some
memorable items from their past you can
examine that they will comment on none
of the other crew are handled this way
so i figured i would get them out of the
way first assuming you have him
installed zaid is likely the first crew
member you will come across assuming you
go to omega first our first meeting with
zaid involves him beating up a batarian
prisoner now you have to remember that
since he is dlc his story is built
around the main story not a part of it
that's why his motivation is extremely
simple he's a mercenary cerberus paid
him a large chunk of credits to do the
job and he accepted it it's straight and
to the point pretty much like zaid
honestly the majority of his dialogue is
just things you would expect a merc to
say he always talks about shooting
things and making money he only goes
this far in his character development
and never goes any further and honestly
i don't mind this zeed is really just
that raw strength we talked about
earlier extra firepower for the team
nothing more nothing less just the
perfect soldier but he's not just
joining cerberus for the credits he made
a deal with the elusive man which ties
into his loyalty mission as thanks for
joining the team we must help zai track
down an old friend of his name vito
you're free to do this whenever you want
but if you want to get to know zaid more
you'd probably want to talk to him on
the ship first a lot of zaid's dialogue
is just war stories about his past
missions one thing zai does mention
quite a bit though was someone called
jessie he says that he and jessie go way
back she wasn't great in combat but was
incredibly reliable jesse had been
through a lot in her life by the time
zaid had met her and he was committed to
her ever since he laid his eyes on her
he also reminisces about their first
mission together where they hunted a
wanted turian and were covered in sludge
from all the sewage they had to go
through to catch him this tale however
ends on a sad note as on their final
mission jessie kept firing and firing on
this squad of enemies before the gun
jammed and she was finished the best
part about this whole story is jessie is
not a woman she's a gun jesse jammed one
day when zaid was using her and that was
the final mission the two went on
without the context zaid really makes
this out to be a love story he even says
putting her down was the saddest day of
his life like i said zaid is a merc
nothing more nothing less and that
really is the best part about zaid it's
like talking to your grandpa about their
war stories in vietnam except it's a
cocky murk in space every time i went
down to talk to him i kept thinking i
wonder what kind of story uncle zaid is
going to have for me today
me and her buddy were hard to take out
this one guy matias i think hell i
forget turns out it was a trap
we got jumped by a hit squad two
batarians a krogan and a hannah
damn jellyfish nearly choked me to death
wore a neck brace for weeks to cover
that up
haven't underestimated a hannah since
z's loyalty mission starts on a planet
called zorya this is one of the few
missions where it actually felt like
shepard was not the one in charge zade
was giving out commands like remembering
to watch out for ambush positions and
checking to make sure the coast was
clear it was a very tactical mission
which fits with his character zaid
manages to tap into some of the comms
and we can hear vito talking to his band
of mercs called the blue suns we'll meet
more of them in archangel's questline
but the three main merk groups in mass
effect 2 are the blue suns the eclipse
and the blood pack all colored and easy
to remember thanks to their primary
color palettes during archangel's
questline is when we get the codex entry
for the blue suns which they said it was
created by a batarian called solemn
however doing this mission gives us
another codex entry called blue sun's
full history this and zaid himself will
tell you that it was actually him and
vito who founded the blue suns however
him and vito had a falling out vito
wanted to hire batarian slaves into
their ranks and zaid was against it this
dispute ended with veto shooting zaid in
the head which is why his face has a
large mark on it zaid obviously lived
this encounter and now holds a massive
grudge against veto for this i want to
clarify the codex entry isn't wrong it's
just not the full story after they're
falling out vito was now the sole ruler
of the blue suns but in an attempt to
not only placate hesbitarian investors
but also prevent possible assassination
attempts against him he crowned solemn
the new leader the blue suns are pretty
much a private military group that gets
paid to guard and kill things there have
been many claims that the group sells
captives to slavers but no one's
actually been convicted of such charges
yet eventually vito and zaid come face
to face and a shootout begins zaid goes
a bit too far and causes a massive fire
in the refinery and now we're left with
a choice save the workers or kill vito
if we save the workers veto gets away if
we kill vito then the workers die this
choice fits perfectly with the new
loyalty system new companions upon
joining the crew are by the game
standards disloyal they don't hate
shepherd but they're not loyal and being
not loyal and disloyal are apparently
the same thing according to the game
this choice will either make zaid loyal
or disloyal to shepherd and i think it's
pretty clear what choices are what
saving the workers is a paragon choice
but it also makes aid disloyal so you'll
have to sacrifice some good boy points
in order to please him it's a decision
between what is morally right versus
doing what's right for the team in the
mission getting zaid loyal will make the
final mission against the collectors
easier so if a few people have to die so
what but on the other side of the coin
someone who willingly puts innocence in
danger is a hindrance to the team
regardless and you can actually take
this idea to its most logical conclusion
if you choose to kill vito he dies in a
blaze of glory with zaid walking off
like a badass if you save the workers
instead vito gets away and in his rage
laid causes a beam to fall on his leg
trapping him if you've already done the
final mission in the game and beaten the
main story you can actually leave zaid
here to die it is the perfect paragon
choice not only did he kill innocent
people but it's clear he doesn't belong
with the team so leaving him to die
would be the perfect fate for someone
like him now most people wouldn't think
to do this after the game is done but
even still choosing this option makes
him disloyal the only way to get around
this is a speech check and while it
doesn't exactly feel realistic to me
that he just is suddenly okay after one
comment from shepard most rpgs have ways
to intimidate or convince people to do
things even if it makes no sense for
them so i'll just go along with it
regardless of your choice in saeed's
fate that conversation is the end of his
loyalty mission as i said his mission is
short since he was added in after the
fact and since the cast is already
bloated enough there wouldn't be enough
time to fully flesh out 12 whole
characters and this idea of giving
characters small missions carries over
to our other dlc companion kasumi is a
master thief and we can tell from our
first interaction that she is very
careful when it comes to revealing her
identity as she uses an advert to speak
to shepard and also utilizes full-body
cloaking to conceal herself although to
be fair she is showing her actual face
on the advert and it's safe to assume
that others around her are hearing this
conversation so maybe that's not the
greatest way to introduce your master
thief character similar to zaid she's
getting paid a lot of money to join the
team and cerberus is footing the bill
kasumi also made a deal with cerberus in
order to join which ties into her
loyalty mission she's looking for her
partner's grey box which is a neural
implant that stores memories thoughts
and secret codes this gray box was made
by her partner kg when he stole
something way out of his league he
encrypted the data and hid it in the
gray box behind all the memories of him
and kasumi so you would have to sift
through all their history in order to
find it not only does she want the gray
box because of what kg found but also
because those memories are the only
thing she has left of him since he died
shortly after the gray box is being held
by a man named donovan hawk who's been
trying to crack it for months and has
had no success kasumi wants us to dress
up nice and fancy and attend a party he
is throwing so that we can get the box
back kg as stated before is her partner
but partner as in lover not business
partner although technically they did
meet while conducting official business
the two of them are thieves and they met
on a job when they were hired to steal
the same painting but instead of
fighting over it they just opted to take
it for themselves and the two have been
together ever since if we go to her room
we can see that she has a few pieces of
art that she stole and kept his
memorabilia there's also a rose which
she used to leave lying around as her
marking to let people know that she was
the one who stole from them and she also
has a really sweet story about a girl
who painted this one particular picture
after she snuck onto a slaver's vessel
and freed her the only other thing of
note in her room is a handful of books
from romance novels to classics this
would be a normal thing for pretty much
anyone but she specifically has
paperback versions of the books in the
world of mass effect media is likely all
digital by now but she prefers as she
says the musty smell of paper in your
hands unlike zaid where most of his
dialogue was war stories from his past
khasumi doesn't actually talk about
herself and mainly comments on the crew
mentioning how joker and edie bicker
like an old married couple and how she's
taken a liking to jacob although she is
unsure if he has a taste for japanese
girls with a penchant for kleptomania as
for kasumi's loyalty mission we travel
to hawk's party and on the way there
kasumi fills us in on some of the
details as a gift we're giving hakk a
golden statue of saren which is filled
with our equipment kasumi and shepard
once inside are going to scope out the
place and look for hawk's vault after
that they'll meet up and see if they can
break inside as you can tell from the
description this is a genuine heist the
mere idea of a heist is always something
that gets your blood rushing as it
usually involves multiple steps and if
the player is a part of the action it
makes them feel like they pulled off the
whole encounter on their own this is a
really cool idea in theory until you
remember that mass effect isn't a
stealth game
you can't be back here
yeah not only are the guns not silenced
but we are literally 15 feet away from
the main hall so we should have
absolutely alerted the whole building i
understand that the devs wanted to make
a really cool heist with stealth and
hacking but it's really hard to do that
when the game has never been based
around stealth at all after getting
through the four layers of encryption
that is hawk's vault we can enter inside
and see all the art he's collected he's
not only collected michelangelo's david
a prothean statue like the one we found
on ilos a fake rachnay queen and various
krogan statues he also has the head of
the statue of liberty according to the
codex lady liberty was the target of
many terrorist attacks since it was
erected in 2096 the statue was taken
down by a terrorist group called
freedom's first who were protesting the
recent induction of mexico and canada
into the north american states this was
one of the major events that sparked
america's second civil war the president
at the time wanted the statue to be
rebuilt using new material while the
original head of the statue of liberty
was held at the national museum of
american history until a battle at
washington dc occurred where the head
was stolen again apparently it somehow
ended up in hawk's vault which is not
even remotely close to earth anymore the
other sculptures can also give us a bit
more info on some of the races as it
seems like turians have art that they
produce but it's very rare outside their
home planets and the other is that
koreans used to write on stone tablets
which hock also has in his vault how we
acquired these is unknown but given his
shady business practices he either stole
them or just had enough money to buy
them probably the best sculpture in this
room though is this creature which is
actually an ogre from dragon age origins
bioware's other rpg say what you will
about hawk the man has excellent taste
in games in the vault is also the grey
box kasumi wanted hack however knew she
was coming to steal it and sets a trap
for us this then leads into a 10 minute
gunfight where shepard will have to
battle through waves of enemies before
being attacked by donovan in a gunship
after enough damage the gunship is
destroyed donovan is dead and kasumi has
her grey box but we run into a problem
the info on the grey box could implicate
the alliance and start a galactic war kg
wants her to destroy the grey box but
that would mean destroying their
memories of them alongside it since it's
a part of the encryption so we either
save the galaxy from an all-out war but
kasumi loses the memories of keiji or we
keep the box but it's stolen again and
it could lead to war for me i decided to
keep the box kasumi isn't going to be
disloyal if we choose the other option
but i figured that she's a master thief
and is a part of my crew so no one's
going to find the box unless they go
through the normandy grief is a terrible
thing to have and it could cause
numerous problems in a person's mind
kasumi could likely become too attached
to the box that she never leaves this
virtual world full of their memories or
she could become a complete emotional
wreck since her partner is dead at the
end of the day i figured that giving
kasumi the chance to see keiji again
even if for a little bit was the right
call kazumi's mission just like zaid was
also pretty short there isn't much to
know about her since she doesn't like
revealing much about her personal life
and her heist was a great idea but a lot
of the novelty was lost once the
shooting began overall though it wasn't
a terrible mission with both the dlc
characters done we can go back to the
more traditional style of dialogue which
involves us asking various questions and
actually having a back and forth with
our companion to start we should
probably begin with the first two
companions we get at the beginning of
the game jacob and miranda he like
miranda doesn't have a recruitment
mission which means their motivations
for joining are going to be the same
both of them work for cerberus so
they're working with shepard because of
the elusive man's orders jacob said that
he served as an alliance member for a
few years but ended up leaving and going
with cerberus instead before leaving
though he was a part of something called
the corsairs it was apparently an
alliance initiative they hired
independent starship captains and used
them for missions that fell outside the
alliance jurisdiction after serving with
cerberus for some time the elusive man
put him in miranda together for project
lazarus and the two have been together
ever since jacob was mostly tasked with
handling the security in case things
went wrong which for him was a pretty
boring job most days one of the
conversations you can have with jacob is
about his family which makes things a
little awkward he doesn't like to
mention his family much because his
father is assumed to be dead that is
until he gets a ping from his father his
private law got an update about the hugo
guernsback which is the ship his father
served on the update was an sos call but
as he said his father's supposed to be
dead since the ship went missing over a
decade ago and he hasn't even talked to
him in over 13 years that's why this
notification is very confusing as this
should not be possible so jacob wants
shepard to go check it out with him when
we travel to the location of the ping we
can see the crash of the ship right next
to us around the ship are various
leftover audio logs and a barely
functioning vi but looking at both of
these sources of info we can uncover a
bit of what's going on here the beacon
that was supposed to send out the sos
call has apparently been in pause mode
for over eight and a half years
furthermore when the crew made it to the
land they started researching the local
food in flora since the rations on the
ship wouldn't last long enough according
to the vi impairment of mental function
seems to occur within a week of
ingesting the flora on this planet with
higher cognitive abilities and long-term
memory suffering over a month this
connects to various logs inside the ship
to talk about how the crew was doing
tests on other members of the crew one
of the logs mentions how one of the crew
members was getting hurt and receiving
bruises only for them to forget what
happened almost immediately after one of
the doctors was also in a panic as she
couldn't remember someone's name on face
and then there's also a very concerning
audio log that talks about one of the
male crew members thinking about taking
advantage of one of the women affected
by the flora considering the fact that
she won't remember after it happens
after leaving we can meet with one of
the women aboard the ship and she too
has lost a lot of her cognitive
functions but she is still able to
barely make complete sentences she talks
with shepard before being attacked by a
group of hunters once the hunters are
killed we find that there's a camp
filled with only women things are
becoming very confusing and also very
concerning and when we meet with jacob's
father it doesn't make the situation any
better when the ship crashed jacob's dad
ronald and the other officers of the
crew kept all the actual food for
themselves while the rest of the crew
was forced to eat the plants what the
plants do though is a bit confusing it
seems like it does impair mental
functions among other things but there
was also a group of hunters that we saw
earlier that seemed to have adapted to
the floor and become resistant or at
least tolerant to its effects this group
of people didn't agree with ronald and
the officers willing on the planet they
were then labeled as outcasts and since
the actual obedient crew could barely
think for themselves they just follow
ronald's orders and defended him once
the crew managed to set up a base of
operations for a time it seemed like
they were keeping the women in one camp
together and were basically pets for the
other officers at this point they were
living like kings and decided that
turning on the beacon was not worth it
so they never did but some of the
officers started feeling guilty about
what they did and decided to activate
the beacon except they were killed
before doing so this now leads us to the
present day where ronald is the only
sane person left in the camp and has an
army of maxim brainwashed guards at his
disposal while all the women are
relegated to their own camp not too far
from ronald himself
he'd hoped the alliance or someone would
come and get him off this planet without
knowing what he did jacob however now
has to come to terms of what his father
has done and honestly thinking that he
was dead likely helped his decision he
feels no remorse for his father and
wants him to pay for what he did this is
a nice twist considering most people
would be happy to sue their parents
after so many years but considering he
wasn't on good terms with his father to
begin with it made his decision easier
plus his father doesn't even seem happy
to see him he's actually more upset that
he discovered what he was up to shepherd
can determine what happens to jacob's
father but all of them end badly for
ronald he either gets jail time for life
or is killed by the hunters jacob is
content with whatever shepard chooses as
he claims that his father died a long
time ago with the log checked out jacob
no longer has any struggles holding him
back and now he's completely focused on
the mission but the question still
remains though who pinged his private
log well as we discover it was actually
miranda she claims that it was because a
few years ago this crash actually
mattered to jacob and she wanted to keep
a promise the two had although jacob has
no clue what that promises but this is
actually a nice segue into miranda
because of all people she would be the
one to remember something like this
that's because she was built to be
perfect in every way combat memory
intelligence looks everything about her
is genetically superior and it's not
because she has some sort of god complex
but literally because she was created to
be this way her father wanted an asset
not a daughter so he created a super
soldier to help further his dynasty
miranda never had a mother because she
was genetically made using her father's
tissue she also says that she wasn't the
first daughter he made just the first
one he kept when she was old enough she
was able to run away from home and join
the cerberus because they were able to
protect her plus her being genetically
superior made it an easy sell since she
could help the company in various
operations but the trauma from living
with her father changed her whole
perspective on life she needs to be
absolutely perfect or it's not enough
she's been told since birth that she was
made to be perfect and the perfectionist
attitude of her father rubbed off on her
and now she won't accept anything less
but the problem is that she's still
human so she's bound to make mistakes
but her mistakes feel greater than
normal because her perfection is
supposed to prevent those mistakes that
really weighs her down a lot and it
causes her to be very blunt with people
she's been labeled as an ice queen by
one of the members of cerberus and
that's pretty accurate when you first
talk with miranda she responds with we
aren't here to make french shepherd stay
focused on the mission eventually though
she will open up the shepherd and that's
because she has a problem that needs
solving a long time ago miranda took her
baby sister from her father because she
knew that the same thing would happen to
her she figured that she wouldn't want
that kind of life so she kidnapped her
and brought her to cerberus where they
made sure she was safe currently she's
living in a city called ilium with her
new parents but she believes that her
father knows where her sister is and is
making a move on her so miranda wants
shepard to come with her so they can
find her together when we meet with her
contact she says that naquette a friend
of miranda's wants to escort her sister
out of illium instead miranda is fine
with the plan as she trusts naquette he
actually helped out miranda back when
she wanted to escape from her father so
she trusts him completely if that seems
too good to be true it absolutely is
niquette is against what miranda did as
he sees it as kidnapping a baby not
saving one i've always felt weird about
this because it's clear naket knew what
was going on with miranda so how could
he not understand why she did it negate
does tell us that her father paid him a
large amount of money to get her sister
back and when miranda says how wrong
that was for him to do he says don't get
holy on me miranda you took his money
for years nakat's motivation seemed to
be all over the place but it doesn't
really matter as he gets killed anyway
and after the battle with this asari
commando we can make sure miranda's
sister is safe miranda gets some time to
talk with her sister and then the group
leaves miranda's mission is pretty short
and it's also one that i'm not too fond
of it's not that it's a terrible mission
i just think there are more interesting
ones in this game it's also kind of hard
to talk about since most of the dialogue
is just back and forth arguing and in
between that is a bunch of fighting so
it's not like some major plot test was
revealed besides the fact that nick had
betrayed her from here though we can
branch out to a few more new and
interesting recruits so let's talk about
jack first because she has a unique
interaction with miranda a bit later
jack is a very powerful biotic and this
caused a lot of problems for her we
first find jack on a prison ship called
purgatory which is run by the blue suns
the warden of the prison states that
after seeing too many criminals escape
he decided to make his own prison it's a
commendable decision of course but money
has to be made if you want to continue
operating the warden has a policy for
this kind of predicament though
basically the home planet that the
criminal belongs to must pay a fee to
keep them in purgatory if they refuse or
miss a payment well they just release
him back on the planet at a random place
in time so clearly he doesn't care about
the escaped prisoners that much if he's
willing to let them go despite it being
in space the blue zones still have some
security measures in case things go
wrong the prison is not only equipped
with turrets and machines dedicated to
keeping the peace but the guards
sometimes use the prisoners to blow off
some steam the warden let shepard know
that once the fun's clear he can go on
his way and when we travel to the
nearest processing wing we realize it's
a trap the warden wants shepard to be a
prisoner instead of a buyer i get where
he's coming from shepherd is a very
valuable person but not even attempting
to subdue him or trick him is very odd
i'm sure the warden feels confident that
he and his guards can take shepherd down
but it just feels weird that he thought
opening the door and asking nicely would
have worked the teen now has to battle
their way to jack instead which makes
things harder but that's not the least
of their problems as jack was captain
cryo for a reason within seconds of
getting out she blasts through all the
mechs and the wall behind them with
enough time she could easily blow a hole
in the side of the prison if she wanted
to this leads to a large firefight with
the blue suns and the warden and
afterwards shepard will catch up with
jack but she is very pissed off as she
has a history with cerberus it takes
some convincing but jack is willing to
come on board but only if she can get
some cerberus files jacka grew up in a
cerberus facility where she was drugged
and tortured daily which is why she
dislikes cerberus so much in fact this
facility is the same one we visit in her
loyalty mission just like miranda a lot
of her upbringing changed how she viewed
life jack likes to stay in a secluded
place away from others and anyone who
tries to talk to her or work with her
likely wants something in return she'll
even question why shepard is trying to
talk to her and will ask if it's because
he wants sex as enticing as that may
sound saying yes actually proves her
point that all you did was talk to her
for sex rejecting her advances allows
you to get to know her more and you can
actually learn more about her past life
she had someone she really liked
sacrificed their life to save her and
she's been dealing with that guilt ever
since jack also worked with a group of
people after escaping the cerberus
facility but they ended up betraying her
eventually too it's because of
everything that's happened in her life
that she turned out the way she did she
doesn't like talking to people she
prefers to be alone and she believes
that she can handle things on her own
over time though shepard can break down
those barriers and allow her to feel
better about trusting a stranger that
isn't trying to use her i really like
the casual sex option that jack has
because it actually penalizes the player
for doing so you have to look at it from
her perspective this commander brings
her on a ship for this mission but now
wants to talk to her given her pass she
assumes that shepard wants something
from her and if you say that you want to
have sex that confirmed her initial
suspicions that talking was only so you
could get in her pants and not because
you cared about her many games even this
one have sex as the final reward some
people might just be talking to these
companions because they want to get them
in bed so by having jack ask for sex
only after a few minutes the player
might think wow that was really easy but
the game tricked them and proved that
they only wanted a relationship to have
sex with them not to actually talk to
the person after jack has enough time to
sift through some of the files she finds
the location of the cerberus facility
where she was held and has devised a
plan to go down there and blow it up
with a giant enough bomb so that she can
see it from orbit just like in mass
effect 1 bringing specific characters
along can provide the player with unique
interactions it only feels right to
bring miranda or jacob to this mission
since they work for cerberus but it's
honestly pretty disappointing i think
this is also due to how cerberus
operates i mentioned earlier how
cerberus works in cells so no one in the
other cells knows of the lazarus cell
which means this mission is a bit
disappointing because jacob and miranda
don't know who these people are so their
only comments are that the facility must
have gone rogue they don't even bother
to question the child experimentation or
any of the work here it's just one or
two comments and that's all it's a
missed opportunity and that's a shame
since cerberus is a major part of this
game so having some of the employees
confront these atrocities would have
been really nice to see one of the
scientists when we look at some of the
logs does say that the elusive men
wouldn't have found out about this and
an email after the mission from the
elusive man states that he wanted the
facility shut down before jack broke out
so it's clear that the facility did go
rogue but i do wish more dialogue
happened between jack and the others we
can interact with various things in the
facility and jack will tell us that
there used to be an arena here for the
kids to fight in jack enjoyed fighting
because it allowed her to get some of
her anger out she also says that when
they fought they would get shocked if
they hesitated but they would be
rewarded with narcotics if they attacked
because of how many times they drugged
her she claims she still gets a tingly
feeling in her veins when she gets into
a fight things start to take a turn
though when we find some old recordings
from the facility before it was
destroyed jack made her life out to be
one that was filled with hardship and
survival she's not wrong but some of the
details are still a bit fuzzy to her she
was considered subject zero at the
facility this is likely because she
showed the strongest potential for
biotic abilities this however actually
benefited her more than she thought one
of the recordings talked about a test
the scientist did which resulted in a
few of the kids dying due to this
failure they opted to not give jack the
drug yeah they were still drugging jack
but they were also giving her these safe
and tested drugs while the other kids
became the guinea pigs she also got her
own room while the kids got to sleep in
small bunk beds she was like the winner
of the loser's bracket she was still
being treated poorly but not as bad as
everyone else this is a bit overwhelming
and conflicting for her because she
remembers things differently it's
because she was only looking at things
from her perspective which goes back to
the earlier comments she made about how
she only looks out for herself and likes
to be alone had she actually talked to
some of the kids she might have realized
how poor everyone was being treated here
at the very end of the level we meet a
man named aresh apparently he was one of
the kids at this facility before it was
destroyed and the riot that broke out he
wanted to come back and restart the
program because he figured all the
testing and drugging was for something
important he's clearly delusional but
it's also understandable why he would
feel this way he just can't accept the
fact that he was tortured and drugged
for no reason he wants to believe that
he was here for a greater purpose and
not just because the scientists were
trying to play god using biotics shepard
tells the guy to leave and then sets the
bomb to blow which i find kind of odd
because you get paragon points for not
killing him here yet the bomb is clearly
going to kill him so i'm not sure how
that works before that though we can
talk with jack and visit her room one
last time she talks about how she used
to be alone here most days and would
hide under the desk when she wanted to
cry there are even some days when she
dreams that she was back in her bed
being tortured and she would tie the bed
sheets around her wrist that she could
break free again but now she never has
to worry about that dark place and its
experiments ever again jack has had a
very miserable life so it's only fair
that she points the blame at someone or
something for causing this and it's this
decision that creates a problem amongst
some of the crew after finishing both
jack and miranda's loyalty mission
shepard will be forced into a decision
jack wants miranda to admit what
cerberus did to her was wrong miranda
refuses to apologize because it wasn't
technically cerberus that did it and she
also calls jack a mistake if you have a
high enough paragon or renegade you'll
be able to tell them both to shut up and
stop but without it you're forced to
pick a side whoever you don't side with
becomes disloyal rendering all your work
in their loyalty mission completely
useless it is possible to regain back
their loyalty but it requires an even
higher speech check as an idea i
absolutely love this i mentioned how i
wanted more of these disagreements in
mass effect 1 and while the characters
still won't go as far as leaving the
crew they can become disloyal which will
have a drastic effect on the final
mission even if they weren't disloyal
the fact that the crew is actually
bickering and arguing with one another
is great it's almost impossible for
these 12 people to get along due to
their unique backgrounds i'm fairly
certain that if all of them were put on
a team that wasn't under the command of
shepard and the entire galaxy wasn't at
stake none of them would get any work
done just from what we've seen from the
five companions we've talked about
miranda and jacob would be able to work
just fine but kasumi zaid and jack
wouldn't furthermore i doubt zai jak and
kasumi would even be able to get along
considering how they fight and act this
group really is a mishmash of different
cultures and personalities all in one
team and being able to see their
disagreements and arguments is
incredible regardless of who you choose
though their loyalty mission will be
complete and jack is a really great
example of how good a companion's
backstory can be mass effect is pretty
consistent when it comes to making the
alien companions a lot better than the
human ones most of the human companions
are pretty dull in this series but jack
is a wonderful exception being able to
help her through her loyalty mission is
one of the reasons i love doing these
missions all of her companions have
things that are eating away at them and
being able to help them through all of
that is wonderful hers is a story of
tragedy confusion and manipulation and
when all those can weave together
perfectly you can really get something
like this our next companion is named
archangel who was last seen on omega
omega is where you pick up morton and
zaid as well as numerous quests that are
started here this place and ilium which
we saw briefly in miranda's mission are
two big locations that the players will
visit omega is basically a slum there is
dirt dust and grime all over the walls
laws barely exist and many people are
living in tiny homes and very little
money the main leader of omega is an
asari named arya although she claims not
to be the leader of omega but the omega
itself which is an interesting way to
boost your ego she'll give us a bit more
information on where archangel and
morton are archangel has apparently
gotten himself into some deep [ __ ] he's
the beacon of light at omega as he uses
the last laws of the place to deal with
crime without the need of authorities
he's also shut down various gangs taking
back stolen cargo and all in all has
caused a major problem for a lot of the
gangs here and they absolutely hate him
those three gangs we talked about
earlier blue suns eclipse and the blood
pack are usually at each other's throats
but they're settling aside their
differences so that they can take out
archangel they're even recruiting
freelancers to use as fodder because if
they throw all their guys at him they
might not have enough members left by
the time they actually kill him the
issue though is that we're going to be
siding with archangel so we're going to
be facing the exact same mercs that he's
facing once we talk to the recruiter and
become a freelancer one of the blue suns
gives us the details on the plan all the
gangs are waiting for certain
preparations to be done so they can move
on in archangel has not only damaged one
of their gunships but also blocks some
of the back entrances where he is so
they have mechanics working on the
gunship and people digging out the
debris from the entrances in the
meantime though the freelancers are
being used as a destruction order to
keep him busy and that's our job since
no one is really moving right now we can
take some time to talk to some of the
merk groups and their leaders we already
discussed some of the blue suns when we
talked about zeed so i won't go over too
much but the leader of this division is
tarik he like all the other bosses have
a personal stake in this mission thanks
to archangel archangel apparently came
to this man's house and almost killed
him so he's been on edge ever since
nearby him is jarroth the solarian who
is the leader of the eclipse the eclipse
was started by an asari commando named
jonah they're a private military company
like the blue suns but they specialize
in sabotage assassination and security
and similar to the blue suns they deny
any involvement in sabotaging and
kidnapping business rivals jarroth has a
dislike towards archangel because he
raided one of his group's transports
last month and killed two of his best
men one of whom was his brother as the
blood pack that's run by a garm a krogan
master the blood pack used to be a group
made up of vorcha which is a new race
added to the game we don't really
interact with many of the vortra through
dialogues they're usually just used as
the bad guys in just about any situation
and that's also connected to their lore
many vouchers live up to 20 years at
most so many don't even bother studying
certain professions and they'll most
likely die before they get any use out
of it the major advantage they have is
that they can eat anything and breathe
anything since they're resistant to all
known diseases this allows them to live
pretty much anywhere they please but due
to lots of racism around the race itself
many aren't accepted into normal society
since many dismiss them as vermin and
this stereotype isn't exactly helped by
all the fighting borchard do as they're
known to assault each other all the time
as inflicting and receiving pain is
pretty much like normal communication to
them this is why most of them are just a
part of the blood pack which is now
under the leadership of a krogan named
gennar who was exiled for hitting a
female krogan who angered him so now he
made a gang in order to gain his honor
back the game quickly gained a lot of
attention and is now seen as another
security company within the terminus
systems but they don't like typical
politics espionage and security that's
what the blue suns and eclipse do they
like jobs with a bunch of violence since
all the group cares about is credits and
killing many customers don't have to
worry about backlash or politics as the
blood pact doesn't really care about any
of that either so as long as they get
the fight they're happy the leader of
this division is garm another krogan he
almost managed to beat archangel on a
one-on-one but the fight had to be cut
short so he's hoping to get another
opportunity to kill him one thing that's
really interesting about the groups is
that it seems like they may be in
business for more than just archangel i
know we can find in one of the rooms is
about the three leaders agreeing that
after archangel arya is next on their
hit list we can give this to arya so she
could sort it out but we never really
see the outcome of this from talking
with all the leaders we can learn about
their plan on taking down archangel and
we can use this information to sabotage
them we can change the friend foe system
on this large mech to have it attack
their allies and we can even kill the
mechanic working on the gun ships that
it starts with less health after enough
time though we are finally able to start
the assault on archangel and we can
finally come face to face with the man
himself
shepard
i thought you were dead
there really was only one person who
loves fighting crime without the law
getting in his way and garrus is that
person we see that he's been doing
pretty well for himself but he's
definitely running out of time garrus
has been doing fine on his own but now
that there's four of us getting out to
be a breeze we have to fight off more
waves of enemies until tarik garm and
jarrod start joining in but we take them
down too tarik manages to injure garris
though and he looks like he's not going
to pull through for a moment obviously
garrus is going to live but he's going
to have a new scar with it talking with
garrus will give us a bit more
information on what he's been up to
though after the normandy exploded he
pretty much went back to what he's
always wanted to do but after a while he
started amassing a team of like-minded
individuals but when we went to the base
we only saw him and it's exactly as you
think all of garris's team got killed by
someone within the group another tyrian
called sedonas sent garris out on a solo
job and while he was out he killed
everyone else on the team in mass effect
1 garris wanted help to take down a
serial murderer sisak couldn't arrest
and once again garrus has another person
on his hit list that needs to be brought
to justice but instead of some random
killer we're going after sedonas this
requires us to go meet with a man named
fade who made sedonas disappear once we
get the information we need garrus will
take a position and wait for the right
moment to kill him shepard is going to
be used as a distraction to get him to
move but you can also tell sedonas that
he's being hunted by garrus i have one
issue with the way this quest is
resolved if you let garrus kill him
shepard steps off to the side and lets
garris take the shot from the way
sedonas reacts it seems like he sees
garrus on the balcony so why is he fast
walking when a sniper is pointed right
at him it's a small nitpick but i've
never understood this if you happen to
spare sedonas though things change we
learn from talking with sedonas that
he's sorry for what he did but he was
forced to do it or else he would have
died instead i like the way this is
handled as it makes the situation a lot
more grayer than it was before the issue
is that we don't know what the situation
was if he was cornered and possibly held
at gunpoint it would make sense why he
took the deal but if he had a chance of
escaping and there was no actual threat
then that doesn't make sedonas look good
it's a hard decision to make but i've
always let garrus take the shot if
sedonas lives he confesses to his crimes
but since it's out of council space and
was probably months to a year ago it's
unclear if he'll actually serve time for
it at least with him dead we know that
he paid for his betrayal out of all the
companion missions in the game i think
garrus is one of the few that can
actually lead to a different outcome
which means that there will be a lot of
different reasons why people chose
specific options so i'd like to know if
you save sedonas in your playthrough and
why while we're on omega we might as
well pick up mordan the solarian doctor
a plague has broke out one of the
sections of omega that seems to kill
everything but humans this has caused
many problems for the humans in that
sector as many believe they're behind
its creation deep within the sector is a
clinic run by morden who despite looking
like a typical doctor really isn't he
used to serve in the salarian task force
under captain kirhy the same one from
vermeyer and one day some people came
into the clinic and demanded money
morton didn't even bother hearing him
out and shot them dead immediately he's
a complete wolf in sheep's clothing arya
says that he's as likely to help you as
he is to kill you shepard gets
outboarded about the collectors and he
immediately agrees to join but we need
to help him with the plague first we
discovered that the collectors were
working with the vorcha and promised
that if they made sure the plague was
successful the collectors would make
them stronger it's unclear why the
collectors thought a plague on omega was
a good idea but it's possible they were
trying to test some experiments of
theirs once aboard the ship we can meet
with morden and he's probably the most
fascinating person to talk to because he
had a hand in the genophage he says that
the krogan actually evolved to resist
the original genophage they had to make
a modified one in order to make sure
they were still affected seeing as he
worked on the genophage it's pretty
obvious that morden saw it as necessary
and it's really hard to understand why
he thinks that until you hear him out he
says that doing this saved the krogan
and while that may sound confusing it
actually makes sense as we know the
krogan became rebellious after the
rakhine war which is why they were
attacked the solarians working on the
genophage ran the simulations and
determined that this was the only
solution had they not developed the
genif h2 things would have happened the
krogan were either going to kill
everyone in the galaxy or all the krogan
like the raknai would have been killed
off creating the genophage stopped the
krogan from rebelling allowing them to
live peacefully with everyone preventing
them from being wiped out the birth rate
is still an issue but by doing this it
made sure the krogan don't overpopulate
and start another rebellion morden tries
to explain to shepard that many people
see the plague as a means to wipe them
out but that was never the actual
intention the silerians were actually
very happy that krogan helped them with
the rock knight which is why they were
trying to save them from themselves this
whole discussion about the genophage
actually relates to his loyalty mission
as one of his students has apparently
been kidnapped on tu chanka the krogan
homeworld when we get to the planet and
start heading closer to melin's location
we find a dead human on the ground none
of this is really important to the
mission but morden shares something
rather interesting shepard is confused
though as why humans like this guy would
be needed as test subjects to cure the
genophage if it only affects krogan
according to morden humans have the most
diverse genetic code in the galaxy he
says that you can look at a krogan or an
asari and pretty much assume their skill
or combat or intelligence but with
humans it's a lot harder to judge
since humans are more diverse it means
that they can react to tests differently
allowing for more results it's pretty
irrelevant regarding the whole mission
but this is one of the reasons i love
talking with morten he's a huge lore
dump for pointless information and
that's what's so interesting about him
despite how impressed he is with using
humans as test subjects he clarifies
that this type of study is unethical
morten is the kind of person who will
say exactly how he feels even if the
person doesn't want to hear it he knows
what he did regarding the genophage was
right and he's not willing to budge on
that fact and he also complements the
data that this team acquired despite it
being very unethical he knows that the
methods to get the results is wrong but
he's willing to admit that the research
they found is rather impressive most
people would see this entire act as
unforgivable morden does too but also
recognizes the positives in things as a
solarian he only has a few decades to
live so he doesn't bother spending the
small time he has on other people's
opinions of him he just gets right to
the point due to this though it can be
really hard to actually enjoy morden's
company given his appreciation for the
genophage and how he even states that
those days were the best of his life but
morden really does care about the people
of the galaxy and was willing to do
something drastic in order to save it
you're saying you were working just as
hard to keep their population from
falling yes could have eradicated krogan
not difficult increased mutation to
degrade genetic structure further chose
not to
rachni extinction tragic didn't want to
repeat all life precious universe
demands diversity
pretty it up however you like you're
talking about murdering millions
no murdered no one altered fertility
prevented fetal development of nervous
system have killed many shepherd many
methods gunfire knives drugs tech
attacks once with farming equipment but
not with medicine
after searching the lab we'll meet with
maylen and discover that he wasn't
kidnapped he actually came to help the
krogan willingly morton is in shock over
this decision as the whole team agreed
that the genophage was necessary so why
is he going against the group's decision
plus he's now using live test subjects
and torture something morton is very
much against maelon says that they
already have the blood of millions on
their hands so what's a bit more if it
gets results morden threatens to shoot
him over this but you can talk him down
if you want to but now morton has the
chance to delete malen's progress or
keep it for another time i chose to keep
the data because i do agree with what
morden says destroying the data would
mean that all the lives mayland took
would be worth nothing but keeping the
data means that their deaths were at the
very least used for something good now
that maitland has been dealt with though
morgan can now focus on the mission at
hand but at the end of the day he is
still a doctor and if a patient is in
need of assistance he's willing to help
them and this is by far one of the main
reasons i love him romance and
companions is back in mass effect 2 and
with it comes one of the most
interesting conversations you can ever
have with morden in mass effect 1 ashley
kaden and liara were the only options
but now that we have a dozen crew
members we have more options at stake
and not just with other humans but with
other species i don't think it's a
surprise given her appearance in the
intro but tali does become a companion
later in the game should the player
pursue a relationship with her garrus or
thane who we'll talk about in a moment
the question of cross species
intercourse has to be answered this
wasn't a problem with liara since asari
don't require physical contact but for
the others that's different if you
pursue a relationship with any of these
three you can talk to morden and he'll
mention how he's noticed the two of you
have become more flirty with one another
and as a doctor he is worried about what
could happen if sexual intercourse were
to occur so he gives tips to shepherd on
what meds would be needed and how to
avoid any pain aware that mission is
dangerous
different species react differently to
stress
past relationship with telezora makes
dalliance attractive as stress release
still recommend caution quarry an immune
system weak
could kill her
you have a recommendation as a doctor
telezora acquired antiseptic recommend
you self sterilize as well oral contact
with tissue dangerous take precautions
also forwarding advice booklet to your
quarters valuable diagrams positions
comfortable for both species erogenous
zone overviews can supply oils or
ointments to reduce discomfort gave ed
electronic relationship a demonstration
vids to use as necessary it's such a
simple inclusion but i was blown away
that not only was intercourse between
two species taken into account but that
one of your companions is more than
happy to assist you small details like
this are my favorite in games because
you would hear this and think well yeah
that's actually a good point i hadn't
even considered that and having those
moments no matter how insignificant or
small they may be really enhance your
experience with morden finish though we
can now move on to the next character
but since we're already here on tachanka
i think it'd be a good time to talk
about grunt but we should probably
explain how we got grant first our
initial mission is to find a krogan
warlord named o'keer he's here at the
facility that is being guarded by the
blue suns the reason for their
appearance is because the leader of the
division jidor wanted to create a krogan
army we can even find one of these
members called a tank bred krogan the
tank bred krogan talk about a being
called the glass mother which is the
tank they were born in they claimed the
tank was talking to them and feeding
them memories and info this was just
oakhire but the krogan saw their tank as
their mother okir has a different
outlook on the genophage than most many
krogan ignore the genophage by just
continuing on with their lives and
seeing no point okir does this as well
but he's ignoring the genophage by
creating a superior krogan in a tank
rather than through reproduction the
tank bred krogan in theory would just
ignore the effects of the genophage
allowing the species to flourish again
he ended up working with jedora as they
were able to benefit from his
experiments jidor wanted an army of
krogen and okir wanted the perfect
krogan so any test subjects he deemed
unworthy he would just give to jidor
like that tank bred krogan we found
earlier the sad part though is that a
lot of them were either forced to be a
part of her army or just use this target
practice okir was able to handle most of
the work on his own but he was also
given an assistant ronathanoptis who you
may recognize from mass effect 1. she
worked at saren's cloning facility back
on vermier she doesn't say too much it's
more just about catching up and then
telling her to leave before she gets
killed again but it's nice to see that
some of our actions from the previous
games do have some meaning upon meeting
okie we can see his perfect soldier in
the tank next to him roman we're about
to head out though were interrupted by
jedor who is attempting to kill okir
after the fire fight we come back and
o'keer is dead
apparently gas was being flooded into
the tank so okier had to make sure it
wouldn't kill his perfect creation as a
result the gas was let out into the room
instead and it killed him this small
subversion from the original idea was a
nice touch as technically we were here
to recruit okir but we ended up
recruiting grunt instead grunt along
with a future character named legion are
the only two characters that we actually
don't have to recruit we have the option
to keep grunt in the tank for the
entirety of the game if we want to i
like this option but i can't imagine
many players not opening the tank on
their first playthrough considering how
much trouble we went through just to get
it upon opening the tank grunt charges
and pin shepard to the wall asking for
his name before he kills him grunt was
never given a name in the tank but since
the word grunt was one of the last few
words he heard from o'keer he figured it
would do grunt is still a child though
as he hasn't actually had time to really
develop this is his first interaction
with the real world so even though he
may look old his mind is that of a
child's a lot of the images and memories
o'kir implanted into him don't really
make too much sense but over time he'll
come to understand their meaning grunt
was implanted with a lot of the legacies
of the krogan warlords and okir's own
mindset which is why a lot of it is
centered around violence hatred and
destruction what other human info was
floating around in there less than a
finger deep to sever your spine
you're soft solarian cesare all soft
quarians not so much
turians you have to work the blade i
guess
don't see much point to it though
much point
uh never mind one thing that grunt
struggles with though is his own
survival he sees the thousands that came
before him as weak as they didn't
survive like he did but he also doesn't
see the strength in himself he says that
he was built for strength but never
earned it while those who died were at
least strong enough to try even if they
failed he was given the power to fight
but without earning it so he feels
cheated in a way this reaches a critical
breaking point where grunt is throwing
stuff around and banging his head
against the glass he says that he feels
tense like he wants to kill something
with his bare hands most krogan would
get this feeling but this time it's
different it's more out of a need rather
than a want sadly though we don't have
too much information on why he's doing
this as not only was he born from a tank
but krogan really don't like to share a
lot of their data publicly this requires
us to go to tuchanka and talk with the
clan leader on this planet though is
where another one of our choices is seen
as that leader of the clan is none other
than rex if he died on vermiyer though
his brother reeve will take his place
regardless of your choice the other
krogan that is next to them is someone
called uvank he's a part of another clan
that has recently started a truce with
clan erdnot from looking at both sides
it's clear that ubank's ideals are much
more in line with the reeves rather than
rexes this is due to what rex has been
up to since he became the leader of clan
or not rex has taken the opportunity to
unite a lot of the clans under his name
he's also allowed fertile females to be
shared amongst clans rather than
segregated into their own clan's men
fertile females in the krogan species
are rare so rex has promised that by
joining and offering to co-exist with
them he'll make sure that the women they
have are unharmed this has actually
caused a lot of problems for some of the
other clans as while many of them do
hate rex and his progressive ideals he's
pretty much untouchable because starting
a war with him would mean that they
injure the female krogan at his camp
oddly enough though the idea of sharing
the women was actually the female clan
leader's idea the neutral area they have
is safe so it allows for krogan of any
gender to talk and converse with one
another without the fear of death krogan
women are also free to meet with other
women from other clans as well which
would end up boosting morale for
everybody rex is very optimistic about
his methods which is good and i'm glad
that things are working out for him but
we aren't here for rex we're here for
grunt rex takes a good look at him and
pretty much determines that he's going
through puberty in krogan culture though
it's not as simple as a few hormonal
changes krogan have to undergo the rite
of passage usually tank bread krogan
wouldn't be allowed into er not but rex
makes an exception because he's with us
krogan who are clanless are not
respected especially if they're born
from a tank so grunt needs to do this in
order to gain their respect to set up
the right of passage we'll need to talk
to the shaman who'll explain what to do
grunt will need a grant in order to
progress in krogan culture a krant is
essentially a krogan's most trusted
allies which would be us as for what the
rite of passage is
when we're actually told all we know is
that a lot of shooting will be involved
despite this i really like how it was
handled completing this rite of passage
is supposed to prove that the krogan
doing it is worthy of battle telling
them ahead of time what the enemy would
be would ruin the point this is shown in
repeat playthroughs of this exact
mission going in on a second playthrough
means you already know what will happen
this means you can bring another crew
member that will give you an advantage
and plan your ammo and abilities around
the fight the final enemy of this fight
is a thresher mod which so far has only
appeared every now and then on random
planets in mass effect 1. knowing this
will spawn during this mission means you
can plan ahead you can bring garrus who
has armor-piercing ammo or pretty much
anybody with high damage weaponry you
the player can also plan ahead and
conserve all your heavy ammo until the
fight with the thresher maw which is
exactly what i did and it took down a
sizeable chunk out of its armor planning
ahead defeats the purpose of this
mission you're supposed to use what you
think you need at the time and then deal
with the consequences as they come and
if after all that you can still come out
unscathed then you're more than worthy
of joining the clan after finishing the
rite of passage uvank meets with grunt
and an altercation occurs fighting
between krogan usually results in just
one thing and i'm pretty sure you can
tell where this is going uvank and his
squad mates try to kill shepard and
grundt but they fail but now that all
the hurdles have been overcome grunt is
now a part of clan erdnot with shepard
serving as his battle master the one who
will guide him towards his enemies and
give him the fights he so rightly
deserves and because of this induction
grunt now has officially quelled his
mysterious urges and is now a full-grown
krogan adult after doing the horizon
mission the one where we met ashley or
cayden the illusomen will give us info
on the last four crew members the first
two that we'll talk about though are
samara thane both of them are wonderful
additions to the team as they can
provide more info on the races within
mass effect to get to them though we
need to go to ilium ilium seems like a
really beautiful and safe place but many
people have just called it a fancier
looking omega in this place though is
liara who now works as an information
broker this is around the time that
she'll tell shepard how she managed to
find his body and how she and farin were
hired by cerberus to do so we'll talk
about her later though as she is a part
of an incredible dlc outside of her
office is not only gianna from novaria
but also a person who claims to be a
messenger for the rachni queen talking
with gianna is more just about catching
up and helping her with another quick
job but it's mostly just asking how
she's been since then as for the rack
and i queen she left a message for
shepard saying that she is grateful that
he decided to spare her and is willing
to help the fight against the reapers
when necessary but seeing as we don't
fight any reapers in this game she won't
be heard of again until mass effect 3.
to get to samara we'll need to talk to
officer dara but sitting in front of her
is sheala from pharos her skin tone has
changed a bit though but she believes
that was a side effect of the thorian
but she said that she's been continuing
to help the people of pharos and she
even gives us a chance to continue
helping them with a quick side quest
ilium is really where a lot of the
changes in the game start to take form
it's only been about five minutes and
we've already talked with three
characters in the previous game if they
died though none of them will appear and
shiala is replaced by a random colonist
from pharos once again there are small
changes and you're only really going to
be talking to them for a few minutes
before they leave but it is nice to see
some of the consequences of our choices
once we do talk to officer dar she'll
tell us that samara being here on ilium
is strange that's because samara is an
asari justicar justicars are essentially
seekers of justice they've taken an oath
that forbids them from having children
starting a family and having other
worldly possessions other than their
clothes and weapons the reason samara's
appearance is odd is because justicars
only stay within asari space and never
travel outside of them this is due to a
number of reasons but one is more of a
consequence of leaving and that's the
code they follow drastic cars see things
as purely black and white which can be a
problem if something is morally gray so
for example if someone was caught trying
to steal food because they're poor and
can't afford it samara would kill that
person because they're stealing without
considering why they're doing it in the
first place it's pretty obvious to see
how this can be a problem but all asari
are aware of how justicars operate but
the other races may not understand why
they do the things they do which can
cause some problems for not only the
justicar herself but also the asari race
as a whole this is why they prefer that
justicars operate in asari controlled
spaces as at least everyone there is
well aware of their existence but samara
clearly wouldn't be leaving an asari
homeworld without a reason to do so and
that's because of her daughter morint in
the mass effect 1 video i briefly talked
about the term ardat yakshi morint is
one of them and samara has come here to
determine his systems to kill her but
for samara to join we need to strike a
deal she helps us deal with the
collectors while we find the ship more
recently left once that she has a lead
on her daughter samara sadly won't be
able to personally help us though as she
has to be taken into custody but the
justicar code has rules for this
justicars are obligated to cooperate
with the police for only one day
afterwards they're forced to let her go
however she won't be allowed to leave
that early and this goes back to the
code since they're forcing her to not
comply with the code she's taken she
must kill them justicar rules are
definitely an oddity but it is
fascinating to see it play out in game
the detective knows the code and knows
what will happen if she disobeys but she
also has to follow her boss's orders so
she's kind of stuck that's why shepard
finding the name of the ship is
incredibly important not just for samara
but everyone within a 40-foot radius of
her
i wish you were willing to go with the
human justicar
i've been ordered to take you into
custody if you won't leave you risk a
great deal by following your orders
detective
fortunately i will not have to resist my
code obligates me to cooperate with you
for one day
after that i must return to my
investigation i will be able to release
you that soon you won't be able to stop
me
finding the name of the ship is pretty
easy we'll just follow the breadcrumb
trail to when asari commando who has the
name of the ship on her data pad after
we give samara the details on the ship
she now has to be sworn into shepherd's
service so that shepard's orders and the
orders of the code don't conflict with
one another basically samara will now do
whatever shepard wants but it's not all
it's cooped up to be samara states that
if shepard makes her do anything
dishonorable while in his service she
will comply but once shepard releases
her from his code she's free to kill him
right after once amar enters the
normandy she takes a bit of time to
settle in but after a while she will
come to shepherd with her loyalty
mission talking about samara is actually
a great time to bring this up as this
affects all the characters going forward
but i've never been a huge fan of how
this was handled all the characters
we've discussed up until now are
recruited pretty early in the game so
you have time to get to know them more
but because samara is only introduced in
the latter half of the game her loyalty
mission comes a lot faster than others
it only takes like two missions for her
to give you the details many of the
companions like garrus and morden don't
get their loyalty missions until after
horizon which would mean you would have
to wait about five or six missions
before anything develops this problem
though is likely due to the size of the
game if i'm not mistaken mass effect 2
was one of those games that required
multiple discs in order to play which is
probably why they sectioned off some of
the cast until after horizon instead of
adding them all at once i think the game
is fine the way it is now but it's clear
that some corners had to be cut and it's
definitely showing with these last four
crewmates as stated earlier samara's
daughter morin does an ardhadyakshi so
she has come here to kill her this is
something within asari culture that has
existed for ages and many assume that
the condition only affects pure blood
asari samar goes on to say that killing
morinth has become the most important
thing in her life and is the reason she
became a justicar 400 years ago samara
had a family prior to being a justicar
she had three daughters all of whom are
yakshi which would mean that samara made
it with another asari in order to create
them i want to clarify that purebloods
being ardot yakshi is more of a theory
rather than facts but it hasn't been
disproven yet not all pure bloods are
arda yakshi liara and samara are great
examples but all ardot yakshi are pure
bloods which is why the theory exists
when one does become an arda yakshi they
are given the option to live out their
life at home away from others or die two
of her daughters agreed morons did not
morons chose freedom but is now being
hunted as a result it sounds like
imprisonment but arayakshi are treated
this way due to their unique condition
the condition is a rare genetic disorder
when an ardot yakshi mates with you the
melding of the nervous system is not as
gentle when we discuss the races in mass
effect 1 i talked about how asari meld
the genes of their partner together
during intercourse morenz does the same
thing but it's more pain than pleasure
she pretty much burns your brain and
kills you a great example is to think of
the arda yakshi as another name for a
succubus the reason this is such a
problem is because the genetic condition
treats this like an addiction once they
get the feeling of killing someone for
the first time they are hardwired to
continue doing it morinth like any
addict will need a fix to keep her going
so she continues to search for people to
mate and kill this actually wouldn't
really be that hard for morenth as asari
are known to be the most beautiful race
in the galaxy but morith loves the chase
she finds that manipulating her partner
into being hers is just as fun as
killing them it's sickening but it's
incredible the asari are probably the
most detailed race in this game and i
love hearing more about their culture
which is why i love samara as a
companion as not only does she provide
us with more info on the justice cars
but also the ardayakshi to find more
we're gonna need to go to omega and talk
with arya who will have more information
it's not much but a girl was recently
killed and it seems to fit the mo of
morinth we can travel to the slums and
talk to diana about her daughter neff
going through her things is critical to
not failing this mission it will allow
shepard to gain insight into what [ __ ]
likes because the plan is for shepard to
be the bait once the two are alone
samara will arrive and take her out if
you don't attract her or choose the
wrong options on the dialogue wheel
morinth will leave and samara will not
be loyal one thing i like about samara's
loyalty mission is that she is one of
four companions that can have their
mission fail and one of two who can die
during it zaid is the only other
companion that can die during their
mission but as we know that's under a
very specific circumstance of beating
the game samara has the potential to die
no matter what the circumstances also
unlike zaid there is no way to convince
her with a speech check if you fail
tough [ __ ] assuming you aren't safe
scumming this makes the stakes of the
mission that much higher as there are
numerous ways to fail this mission if
you manage to succeed though samara and
moreth will be at a standstill leaving
shepard to decide who to kill while i am
glad that they give the player the
option to choose i have never found a
good reason for actually keeping moritz
alive gameplay-wise her abilities are
pretty much the same as samara minus one
ability and narratively it makes sense
to kill morin i'll be honest i have
never killed samara once until now and i
absolutely hate it morin terrifies me
because after killing samara she says
that she will join us and to not worry
about the crew as she can imitate her
mother and that's the part that scares
me not only is she talking and dressing
like her dead mother but she's
incredibly good at it i'm a dead ringer
for my belated mother
few people can tell us apart and i've
practiced long and hard to mimic her in
every way
if i closed my eyes i'd swear you were
samara it took years to perfect but when
i was younger posing as my mother
brought its advantages how do you think
i originally escaped from thessia let me
just slip into this horrible uniform and
none will be the wiser no one on the
crew with the exception of kasumi will
even notice this but even then kasumi
promises not to tell anyone it's just
weird to look at morin than see her act
like her dead mother that we helped kill
also to make matters worse morinth is
still on ardatyakshi if you complete the
game and choose to romance more and
afterwards she will kill shepard during
it as if you needed more reasons to not
have her on the team but with that
finish samara is no longer bothered by
anything and is willing to help shepherd
on his mission since her 400-year quest
to kill her daughter is finally complete
since we found samara on ilium it's only
right to go back and pick up our next
companion thane whereas samara added
more depth to the asari race dane adds
more depth to the world as a whole by
adding a whole another race into the mix
dane is in the middle of an
assassination so we're gonna need to
hurry if we want an opportunity to speak
with him his target is nasana dantius
she had a small sidequest in mass effect
1 which revolved around us killing her
sister who was the leader of a group of
slavers nassana now has a target on her
head so she hired the eclipse merc to
defend her as we approach asana's office
she assumes that we're the assassin
which allows they in the perfect
opportunity to strike unnoticed the
first question you will have when seeing
him is
why does he dress so nice
the second question you'll likely have
is what is he thane is a drill they're a
new race to mass effect and they are one
of the rarest races in the game similar
to how tally's appearance in mass effect
1 was an oddity so too is thanes the
draw were rescued from their own
homeworld by the hannah ever since then
the two have co-existed and have gotten
along very well i briefly talked about
the hanar back in mass effect 1 and i
mentioned how they only share their soul
name with those they're close to since
the drell and hannah became very close
allies many jerrell know the hanar by
their soul names according to thane
hannah communicate using bioluminescence
which also brings up a really good point
one thing i haven't mentioned yet was
how the other races speak to one another
since each race has different ways of
communication and different languages it
is customary for anyone outside their
homeworld to carry translators that
allow them to hear in real time what
they're saying in their language the
reason i bring this up is not only to
provide a reason why everyone speaks
english in this game but because jerrell
don't need a translator for the hanar
many drel have had their eyes
genetically modified in order to
perceive their higher frequencies as a
result though thane is slightly
colorblind ultraviolet light which is
known to be a mix of purple and blue to
us is seen as silver tethane and dark
red and black are the same color as for
why the hannah and jarrell live together
well it's due to their planet the drell
at their apex reached around 11 billion
people in population at this time though
they hadn't achieved star flight yet so
all of them were stuck on the planet
currently in our world we have around
seven and a half billion and people are
already saying that we're overpopulated
as is imagine another three and a half
billion on top of that they were doomed
to die until the hannah found them over
the years they took drought from their
homeworld in order to save their
population however they only managed to
save around 375 000 the rest were left
on the homeworld and likely died out at
some point due to overpopulation and
lack of resources this however still
came with its own set of problems the
drill homeworld is very arid and rocky
while the hannah home world is filled
with oceans this caused many problems
for the race's respiratory systems this
change in environment manifests in a
disease called kepler syndrome something
thane has been afflicted with according
to thane and the codex kepler syndrome
is a bacterial lung disease the henna
tried to create antibiotics to stop the
disease but after a while they became
ineffective the only method that works
is a lung transplant but since the
disease spreads to other organs over
time it's not permanent and is really
just to buy time this is why thane joins
the team since he is dying and likely
won't live another couple years he wants
to make the world a better place while
he's still alive but like anyone with
limited time on their hands thane has
been reflecting on his own past actions
and choices this ties into his loyalty
mission which centers around his son
colyat thane is an assassin and when he
was on the job one day he had the target
in his sights but another draw woman saw
and stepped in front of a shot he was
conflicted because this woman had no
reason to save his target it was simply
because she didn't want thane to kill
them he was stunned and didn't know what
to do so after some time he met with the
woman and she eventually became his wife
but after some time his wife ended up
dying but what he didn't tell his son is
that it was because of him someone
wanted to kill thane but they knew he
was too strong to take on so they used
his wife to get to him thane then
dedicated the rest of his life to
killing those who killed his wife and
once he was successful he'd plan to
reunite with his son but he couldn't
bring himself to do it he had spent such
a long time away from his son that he
didn't know how to speak to him
afterwards plus coliette was likely
angry at him for being gone for so long
so he didn't want to deal with that
conversation thane thought about this
over for years and never did anything
about it but now that he's dying he
wants to make things right before he
passes he managed to use some of his old
contacts to track down his son and
discover that he has become disconnected
thane believes in the old religious gods
of the drill which say that the body and
soul are different the soul is the real
self and the real person and when the
soul and body work together they become
a whole person when someone is
disconnected it means that the body and
soul aren't operating together this can
be both mental and physical so if
someone is weakened by fear or despair
the soul is disconnected from the whole
person but if someone is physically
injured then the body is disconnected
from the whole person thane sees the
body as a vessel that people use to
commit acts similar to how a person uses
a gun to shoot someone where someone
would see the person as the killer in
that situation thane would see the gun
as the killer this allows him to absolve
himself of his crimes because he claims
that it was his body that did it not his
soul koyat has somehow discovered dane's
old contacts and has now taken up
assassination work he doesn't want koya
to become like him so he wants us to
track him down if we ask why he needs
our help he'll say something quite odd
zayn i don't have your contacts and i
don't have your tracking skills why do
you need my help for this i don't need
your help i want it
the last time i saw my son they wrapped
her body in seavines
waited with stones
he tries to pull from me
calls
he begs them not to take her away they
let her body slide into the water
he hits me don't let them
stop them
why weren't you
it always rains on kaje
warm water pours down his face
one thing drel excel at are remembering
memories they are able to perfectly
remember just about every moment of
their lives down to the emotions they
were feeling at the time this can cause
some problems for the gel as while
they're able to relive happy memories
some can become too attached so that
they never end up interacting with
anyone and live a life of seclusion but
the same is true for the bad moments in
our life over time the human mind
completely forgets memories or loses
some of the smaller details we all
remember the most embarrassing moment of
our lives but after some time the
details and the timeline events can be a
bit blurry but for drell they remember
every detail perfectly and it could be
very traumatizing for them they need
shepard to track down his son so that he
can meet with him before he dies similar
to samara if you don't catch koyat in
this mission then you fail and dane is
not loyal to shepherd in order to find
koi yet we have to tail his current
target then prevent him from following
through with the kill once we spot him
if you succeed koyat is cornered with
shepherd thane and c sec blocking the
entrance thing then takes the
opportunity to talk to kolyat and
explain why he wasn't a better father
captain bailey then takes coyote into
custody but shepard can't convince him
to just give him some community service
bailey also allows the two to talk more
in private afterwards we can ask dane
how it went and he says that while koyat
is still having trouble opening up and
forgiving him he is hopeful that after
some time the two will be able to
reconcile and become father and son
again thane is easily in my top three
companions for this game he's a very
honest and spiritual person and for him
to share all that information with us is
wonderful not only showing how much he
trusts shepard but also showing how much
he actually enjoys our time together
thane has only told shepard about how he
met his wife and even tells shepard that
he is the first friend he's had in the
past 10 years he's a really sweet and
considerate person and learning about
his spiritual side was interesting as
it's a rather unexplored topic in the
world of mass effect at least when it
comes to actual dialogue as most of it
is just delegated to the codex hem on
kira lord of hunters grant that my hands
be steady my aim be true and my feet
swift
and should the worst come to pass
grant me forgiveness
both samara and thane had a lot of
information to go over and for people
who are unfamiliar with their background
or even the game in general that could
have been a bit overwhelming so let's
take it easy for a bit and talk about
someone we're already familiar with our
11th companion is tali zoro tali of
course being the same quarry and we met
back in mass effect 1. we also meet her
earlier in the game on freedom's
progress although that meeting was pure
coincidence but now we're specifically
trying to recruit her she is located on
a planet called haystrom tali is here to
conduct research as this planet used to
be a home colony of the quarians and
seeing as they live on ships now it
makes sense why they're trying to
explore other planets as soon as we
arrive not only are geth here but
something is wrong with the sun when we
step into direct sunlight the sun burns
our shields tally was sent here to
uncover why this is the case we can
actually find some of her notes on the
planet but there isn't much to go off of
the only thing we can learn is that the
planet is burning their equipment so
they're struggling to get any accurate
readings tali also mentioned shepard's
name numerous times in their audio logs
which is really sweet and shows how much
of an impact he has made on her since
they met two years ago when we make it
inside the base camp we can listen to
another audio log of hers that talks
about how her ancestors used to live on
this planet without their helmet so the
sun must have been normal back then this
also connects to the architecture of the
base as there is a lot of stone
everywhere and if we remember kasumi's
mission we know that the koreans used to
write on stone tablets after defeating
loads of geth and helping out one of the
last members of the team survive the
fight we can meet with tali who gives us
more information on the sun according to
tali the sun is destabilizing and she
hypothesizes that it's because of dark
energy affecting the sun's interior
apparently the effect is similar to when
a star explodes to enter a red giant
phase but hastrom's sun is too young for
that to be natural if you thought there
would be more info on this or that there
would be any damning consequences you'd
be wrong this never gets brought up
again and it's likely tied to a plot
line that was going to be developed for
the sequel but never came to light
former writer on mass effect drew
carpishin originally planned for the
game to have a dark energy plotline i'm
going to paraphrase a lot of what he
said but basically dark energy was going
to be something only organics could
access and use one of the things the
writers discussed was to have the
reapers kill off species because of that
dark energy he was going to have the
game mention how organic life would
slowly evolve and adopt biotic powers
and dark energy but doing so would kill
the universe haystrom sun is likely
going to explode due to the use of dark
energy so imagine this is a sort of
ripple effect that occurs throughout the
whole galaxy wiping out the entirety of
the milky way the reaper's motivations
for killing off each species each cycle
was going to be so they could preserve
the universe and prevent its inevitable
destruction at this point in mass effect
2 we still don't know why the reapers do
what they do and we won't learn until
next game but i do want to clarify it
has nothing to do with this dark energy
plot a lot of the lore regarding this
wasn't fleshed out yet as it was still
early in development drew was likely
going to continue with this idea but
since he wasn't a part of the team
anymore the plot got scrapped in favor
for the one we have now to this day
haystrim sun is one of the many things
left unexplained in the mass effect
universe and it is a damn shame that we
didn't get to see this original idea
come to light after saving tally we can
ask her if she wants to join the team
and she is more than happy to similar to
garrus tally doesn't need a reason to
join not only is she with shepard again
which is reason enough she's already
aware of the reaper threat so she
doesn't need to be convinced once tally
joins though things get a bit hostile we
know from freedom's progress that
cerberus attacked the fleet so she's
very reluctant to talk with any of them
just like many of the companions in this
game even though they are a part of
cerberus they aren't working for them
they're working for shepard who just so
happens to be employed by cerberus to
make things worse right as soon as she's
about to leave jacob introduces her to
edie who is an ai and given her history
with the geth she is even more
displeased to hear that news just like
in mass effect 1 tali will be in the
ship's core making sure it runs smoothly
but after some time she'll run into a
problem tali's been called back to the
migrant fleet so that she can face trial
for treason apparently tali has been
accused of sending live geth back to the
fleet but she claims to have only sent
parts and pieces so being the helpful
commander we are we're going to help
tally out again not only is this a great
mission because we get to help her out
but we finally get to visit the migrant
fleet from what's holly has told us the
migrant fleet sounds like a marvel and
it is marvelous indeed the fleet
consists of 17 000 ships which is so
many that it could take days for all the
ships to use one mass relay it's also 17
000 ships flying together in a group
just the idea of that sounds amazing as
we approach the fleet we hear to holly
call to them as talizor of osnima naraya
the naraya was a part of her name in
mass effect 1 but the vas nema is new
basically in korean language vos means
the name of the current ship you serve
on and nars which ship you were born on
so tali serves on the nema but was born
on the raya this will change as tali's
new name is now tali zora vos normandy
as the council had her name legally
changed now that she serves on shepherd
ship right after this tally also lets
them know that they will need a security
and quarantine team because the normandy
is not clean as we know koreans due to
their weak immune system take their
cleanliness very seriously so making
sure the ship is clean and sure that no
bacteria or germs will infect them once
again more small pieces of insignificant
lore that i'm more than happy to learn
about once we get to the trial we get
the unfortunate news that because we're
the captain of the ship tally belongs to
we have to represent her in the trial
this is told to us literally 10 seconds
before one of the admirals says that the
trial will be easy as the only rule they
have is to present the truth as best as
possible without using legal tricks and
political loopholes
how ironic even worse tali is told right
then and there at the trial why her dad
is not present because he's likely dead
despite how much of a disadvantage
shepard is in right now at this trial he
gets a lucky break as he offers to go to
the ship that was attacked to find out
what happened it sounds a bit weird to
stop a trial like this but shepard can
tell the board that the safety of the
fleet comes first which they agree on
this not only makes shepard look nice in
front of the board but also allows him
mentality to gain more knowledge on what
exactly happened here as it's possible
they could exonerate holly if they find
the right evidence before we leave we
can meet with some of the admirals to
get their thoughts on the trial and even
their own ideals the admirals that were
present at the trial were admiral zen
chorus and han gerald admiral's end is
more concerned about the safety of the
fleet over anything else but also has no
issues studying the get that she wants
him to go back to the servants they were
supposed to be admiral han geral also
wants the fleet to be safe but he wants
to go to war with the geth so that they
can retake their home and admiral korres
is a geth apologist he believes that the
koreans are wrong to destroy them he
wants the people to focus on finding new
colonies to live on rather than retake
their old homeworld tali's aunt
charleron who announces the trial
doesn't sway any particular way and
tali's father rail is likely dead so his
spot on the admiralty board will need to
be filled so currently all the admirals
are at a standstill regarding their
decisions as the party is all split the
other people we meet here are kal rieger
who we met on haystrom and vitor from
freedom's progress if we chose to give
vidor back to tali we can see that he's
slowly but surely making a full recovery
if we gave him the service for
questioning though he'll still be here
but he doesn't seem to be improving in
fact he is scared of our presence if cal
was either told to stand down during the
fight or told to help and shepard
manages to kill the geth colossus quick
enough kale will survive other than that
he's dead after talking with everyone we
can proceed to the ship most of the
encounter is fighting but every now and
then a logger datapad is found with some
info on the crew it seems like the crew
here was performing experiments on
geth's systems as they were trying to
look for new ways to overcome the death
it's some info on what was going on but
not enough to explain as to why the
gether on board the ship in the room
next to them shepard and tolly find
tali's father who died during the attack
you can use a paragon interrupt to
comfort her and it's a really sweet
moment tali is genuinely one of the
nicest companions in this trilogy and
she clearly doesn't deserve to go
through this so hugging it out lets her
know that she's not alone in this world
after their quick hug tally finds a
message from her father and it's about
what to do when she finds the message
rail knew that his daughter would want
to find him so he left her a message
fully knowing she would find it this
makes her feel a bit better as it shows
that her father even in his final
moments still wanted to help his
daughter at the end of the level is
where the real evidence is shown rail
and the crew of the ship wanted to
create live geth so they could test
weapons against them but they were too
ambitious and the geth escaped and
killed the crew one of the crew says
that they would be able to get more
progress done had tali actually sent
active death instead of parts but her
father purposely wanted tally out of
this business so that she wouldn't be
put on trial he wants no harm to come to
her because he wants her to be safe he
was also incredibly dedicated to this
project because he promised tally that
he would build her house back on their
homeworld before he died but as we can
see the love of his daughter clouded his
judgment and ended up getting the crew
and himself killed while we have enough
evidence to prove that tali is innocent
we run into a problem presenting this
info would exile her father which would
remove his name and accomplishments from
all the quarian data almost like he
didn't exist in the first place even
though he is dead tally doesn't want her
dead father to be known as one of the
worst war criminals in quarry in history
so shepherd is presented with a few
options at the trial if you go to the
trial and show the evidence tally is
innocent but you lose her loyalty
because we exiled her father if we don't
provide the evidence tally is exiled but
she stays loyal because we didn't exile
her father however we have the option to
also use the speech check which has
tally exonerated without the need of
evidence meaning she is loyal to us
anyway or on the rare case she managed
to save vitor cal rieger and talk to the
admirals prior to the mission you can
rally the crowd as the game says which
has vitor and kale speak on her behalf
allowing her to win the trial and
allowing us to gain her loyalty this is
a lot of options and i love the
differences between them going above and
beyond and making sure we get the best
of both worlds requires shepard to do
things outside the trial and unique
requirements should provide unique
results if shepard didn't take these
options he's forced to choose between
the lesser of two evils both of which
will not end in a happy ending for
everyone i really love the way this
finale was handled and how wonderful the
mission itself is in regards to its lore
and background i don't think i need to
say this but tally's quest is fantastic
tally as a person is probably my
favorite companion in the trilogy
although garrus does give her a solid
run for her money being the figurehead
of corey and knowledge in this game i've
always enjoyed talking with her every
conversation or interaction with her
always seems to provide more insight on
the korean people and their thoughts on
the get and speaking of geth we should
probably wrap this whole section up by
talking about our final companion in the
game legion legion is found during the
reaper iff mission which would have been
included in the collector section when
we discussed those missions about a
century ago but i wanted to hold off on
talking about it until now as a recap we
need to find the reaper iff because the
reapers use a friend foe system to
determine who can cross the omega 4
relay safely this iff will make sure we
don't get killed immediately upon using
the relay and there just so happens to
be one on a derelict reaper floating in
the middle of space after entering the
reaper we can see that a research team
has set up a base here in order to study
it as you would expect though things
went wrong pretty quickly not only are
there husks here which implies that the
crew was killed but there was a
recording of two guys who apparently had
the same wife their memories seem to be
merging with one another which is why
they can recall the same exact details
about their wife clearly the crew is
going mad and being indoctrinated and
another audio log will confirm this as
one of the crew talks about some god
likely in reference to the reapers once
shepard makes it further into the reaper
a husk shows up behind him but luckily a
sniper is able to save him until it's
revealed that the sniper is a geth but
this is no ordinary geth as it is our
new companion legion once shepherd finds
the iff we can meet with legion but he's
knocked out by one of the husks shepard
then destroys the reaper core and takes
legion back to the ship similar to
grunts shepard can refuse to activate
him and instead sell legion to cerberus
if we activate him though we learn a lot
more about legion and the geth legion is
a geth mobile platform he also seems to
be a bit rare in regards to other mobile
platforms geth are originally synthetic
code so the body they use is really just
a body each geth comes at roughly 100
programs equipped within them these
programs then form inside the geth which
they call a mobile platform it's almost
as if a hundred voices were talking and
controlling a body at the same time
legion is special as he was specifically
designed to operate alone outside the
geth homeworld so he has over 1100
programs that inhabit the body as we
know geth have the ability to expand
their neural network tali says that the
more death there are together the
smarter they are since legion has 1100
programs compared to the normal 100 or
so that regular geth have that means
legion is 11 times smarter than a normal
death soldier that is also why legion
refers to himself as we because he's
talking about all the individual
programs that reside in the body this
was also why legion was given so many
programs because with all that power he
could operate on his own and do what he
was intended to do which was to
communicate with organic life outside
the geth homeworld while normal guts
would likely not be able to do this on
their own since they lack enough
programs in bandwidth i know this may
seem confusing because ever since the
start of the series we have seen geth as
these robotic bodies but in legion's
loyalty mission we can see what's called
a hub which contains millions of geth
inside remember they are just lines of
code so they're able to exist in small
spaces like this the question still
remains though why is legion trying to
find shepard he calls out to him when
they first meet so there must be a
reason well legion was searching for
commander shepard because they have
mutual goals shepard and legion both
hate the heretics and the old machines
the old machines are what they call the
reapers and the heretics are the bad
geth legion followed shepard by
retracing his steps all the way back to
eden prime he ended up finding the crash
site of the normandy which is why he's
wearing part of shepherd's n7 armor up
until this point we may have assumed
that all geth wanted the same thing but
since they have sentience they have the
ability to think for themselves the true
geth which legion is a part of are the
ones that hate the reapers the heretics
are the ones who allied with the reapers
and the ones we've been fighting since
mass effect 1. legion also briefly
mentions a being called nazara in this
conversation which he says is the name
of the being we call sovereign this is
likely sovereign's actual name as we
know that reaper is the wrong term
sovereign even says in mass effect 1
reaper a label created by the protheans
to give voice to their own destruction
as for how sovereign even contacted them
the reapers like the geth were listening
in on organic radio transmissions and
from listening to them is how the
reapers learned about the death war with
the quarians and then sovereign sought
them out and recruited them this whole
conversation is fascinating as it
implies that not all geth want to fight
organic life and simply just want to
exist furthermore heretic is oddly
specific a heretic is someone who has
views opposite of the current church's
views this would mean that the geth have
some sort of religion they believe in we
briefly saw a bit of this on pharaohs as
some of the guests looked like they were
praying to something but it's unclear if
the heretics have a different religion
than the true geth do but fighting the
reaper isn't the only reason they want
shepard's help the heretics have created
a weapon something morrick into a virus
and when activated we'll rewrite some of
the code in the geth to make the true
geth join the side of the heretics
legion was sent to stop it which is why
he was seen at the reaper core when we
arrived to stop this virus though we
need to make it to the heretic station
on the edge of the terminus system as
you would expect by now there is a lot
of combat in between a lot of dialogue
when we arrive legion will say that
shepard has the option to either destroy
the geth or convert the heretics to the
true geth thus doing the opposite of
what the virus was intended to do when
asked what legion wants he says that
he's unsure out of all the programs that
make up the mobile platform 573 want to
write them 571 want to destroy them
legion isn't able to make a decision
though due to this conflict this is
likely so shepherd gets the final choice
on the matter but it is interesting to
see that not even all the programs in
the legion mobile platform can even come
to an agreement further showcasing how
much sentience the geth truly have this
is even shown to us a bit earlier as
when analyzing the geth hub legion says
that the heretics have copies of their
current patrol routes to organic life
this is normal when dealing with enemies
but to legion this is new when the
heretics split off from the true geth
they let them there was no war between
them the two groups had peace given that
legion is synthetic it's hard for him to
understand the concept of conflicting
ideals and how two people that grow
apart will develop in different ways
meaning their two people won't be the
same anymore after getting to the end of
the station we can choose whether or not
to rewrite the heretics we sadly don't
see the outcome of this decision and for
war reasons it actually makes sense
according to legion anyone connected to
the geth neural network will change
within a day however any of the mobile
platforms like legion won't be affected
until they connect back to the network
so many of the death we would fight in
side quests and such likely haven't
become infected yet as they haven't had
an opportunity to plug into the network
once the crew escapes the station legion
becomes loyal meaning all of our
companions are loyal to shepherd as you
would expect though tali and legion
don't get along and the two have a
disagreement legion was trying to scan
tally's omni tool and send back data
about the flotilla to the geth legion
found data that suggested the quarians
were performing weapons tests and were
discussing plans of attacking the geth
so legion figured he would warn them
similar to jack and miranda you can
either use a speech check or pick a side
if the speech deck is used and legion
agrees to not transmit the data he found
and has thanks tali will provide legion
with non-classified data about the
flotilla so both parties are satisfied
despite how angry legion might make you
because of this decision we have to
remember that legion was only going to
send the data because his people would
be attacked the geth are not really as
dangerous as they are made out to be
yeah they were created by accident then
their first interaction with organic
life wasn't great but they still want to
interact with organics and be able to
live on their own without being
threatened that's why the geth want to
defeat the heretics as they give them a
bad name it's a new side to the death we
haven't seen yet i just wish we had more
time to talk to legion if there's one
major downside to legion is that he's
found so late in the game that the
player will likely never actually use
them and the squad went on missions
there's so many missions in this game i
would have loved to see legion on like
in horizon or even the collector's base
but we weren't able to do that you're
able to bring him in some of the
recruitment missions but you also have
to risk sacrificing the entire crew in
order to do so i'll explain that later
but if you go a bit out of order you can
actually bring legion to tally's
recruitment and loyalty mission which
means you're literally bringing a guest
to the migrant fleet and all the
interactions this creates are tense or
in cal rieger's case are downright
hilarious
we talked on the radio before that drop
ship arrived you've got to get
right behind you we are allied with
shepard we will fight the death units in
this area
you know ordinarily that wouldn't fly
with me
but i can't afford to be picky right now
bert i can't believe you
guest get down
ally fire sleeping cover requesting
assistant shepard commander
how does that geth know your name
this gift is part of our team it's
fighting the other guest i can explain
it later
i don't think it's a good idea to bring
a
get that dumb thing off my ship before
you start an incident that makes the
ascension project fiasco you're
defending your ship i respect that but
don't try to intimidate me captain
or what
or i take off this mask and breathe
germs all over your nice clean ship
security a death is present in the
courtroom
does charlie zora think to affect this
hearing with threats
furthermore if you remember from tali's
loyalty mission one of the admirals is a
geth apologist and bringing legion here
provides new dialogue
do you think the geth would be willing
to accept a truce with quarians legion
we did not seek hostilities with
creators we fought for continued
existence
so your people would be open to peace
not without additional data that
suggests coexistence is possible or
desirable for creators when the creators
have believed victory is possible they
have attacked us 100 of the time i
understand
it would be difficult to argue for peace
when faced with odds like those that
does not mean the argument should not be
made i've always felt that legion is the
most underappreciated companion in the
game due to him being recruited right
before the final mission i would have
loved to see how he would have acted
during the other companions recruitment
missions like with garrus but unless i'm
mistaken you need to recruit the first
batch of characters before horizon can
start which means it's impossible for
him to be present during the mission
with legion and his mission done however
we've officially talked about all 12
companions in mass effect 2. and by now
you can probably tell that over half of
this video has just been spent talking
about the companions this not only shows
that the companions have way more depth
to them than before but also shows how
little the game has in terms of content
when the companions are taken out and
that may be a problem for some people
during the development of the game one
of the devs said quote the funny thing
is that people say other than gathering
your crew and building your team and
getting ready for this mission there's
not much story there but that is the
story end quote while i personally like
this game's story i could see how many
people will be upset by this decision we
finally got to see the main throat of
the game in action but now we're focused
on the companions now i saw a couple
comments on the previous video that said
mass effect 2 was the weakest game in
the series and i can't blame you if you
think that way there are only 4 missions
in this game regarding the reapers which
is a third of the number of the
companions we have on our team while i
am glad that we learned more about the
reapers and the collectors and we still
have more things to learn about them
that i'll get to in a moment i would be
lying if i said that i'm glad the
reapers were pushed to the side as much
as they were in this game at the end of
the day though at least the content we
did get was worth it all the companions
just like their gameplay all provided
unique experiences to the story some
added new races some added new roles in
social systems others were just more of
the same but one thing that they shared
was that each mission was personal to
them even though a few of the missions
weren't that interesting to me the
feeling that what i was doing was deeply
personal to them was there at every step
not once did any mission feel
unimportant each character had different
problems plaguing them and i was more
than happy to help them with their
issues after all they were helping me
with my biggest issue taking down the
reapers so it's only fair that i helped
them with theirs the only complaints i
did have though were that some of them
were just not that interesting to me i
said quite a bit ago that many of the
human companions weren't as interesting
with the exception of jack this problem
corrupted mass effect 1 as well for
likely the same reason ashley and caden
and while interesting couldn't hold a
candle to the other four as they were
from different races and different
cultures most of ashley and caden's life
is already known because they're human
we don't need to ask what gods they pray
to how they eat or are their immune
systems different because we already
know this carries over into mass effect
2 as each character that wasn't the five
humans either added new insight into
their racist culture and background or
already did that in mass effect 1. out
of the others jack was are the one that
stood out the most jack's story built
upon the idea of biotics and ran with it
showing the player how horrible the
experiments were and what life was like
for the kids that were subjected to it
zeit and kasumi's missions were short
which is the main reason i'm giving most
of them a pass as if they were longer i
likely wouldn't have joined them i
understand that not everything has to be
about a life-changing event and can be
something as simple as killing someone
who wronged you but we've also killed
thousands of other blue suns already yes
veto was different but the only
difference is that he had a name as for
jacob and miranda i found myself happy
by the end of each mission but only
because it was finally over i think a
major contributor to this was their
personalities jacob is just a typical
cerberus soldier and miranda was created
to be a perfect biotic nothing ever goes
farther than this and their loyalty
missions didn't really help that much
either they aren't the only characters
with lackluster or repetitive ideas as
garris is still the same old garris
personally i'm fine with this because
garrus comes with a lot of charm but
even still they managed to weave his
idea of what it means to enact justice
into his loyalty mission and give us a
chance to think about whether or not
sedonas deserved it jacob and miranda
were more about daddy issues and while
miranda's made sense i still found both
of them to be disappointing but that's
okay you aren't going to nail it every
single time and as a complete package
though there were a lot more good
companions than bad ones before we
continue where we left off it's about
time we talked about the side content
and dlc in this game this section of the
game's content really shows off its best
and worst looks the side quests are
similar to mass effect 1 where most of
them involve a small errand with not too
much story involved which as i said in
the prior video is completely fine we do
get a few unique missions like being
able to find the crash site of the
original normandy which i really enjoyed
and you can also travel back to the
citadel for a lot of side missions the
only disappointing part is that the
presidium has not been completely
removed as the presidium floor is really
just the counselor's room when we enter
the room anderson will be there
regardless of our choice if we let them
live then we'll be able to talk to the
council about cerberus and what we've
been up to but if they died in the
previous game we won't be able to see
them at all even though we get to speak
with them it's only briefly and goes
just about how you would expect they
still don't believe in the reaper's
existence and when told to visit ilose
and meet vigil they claimed they did and
vigil was deactivated prior to their
arrival the council's fate as a decision
feels absolutely useless in this game as
we barely interact with them they do
appear more in mass effect 3 so we'll
have to revisit this choice later and
that also brings up a good point about
the decisions of this series the only
major decisions that we get to see in
this game is rex's fate and the rachni
queen but even then it's just one
conversation with each of them hell we
only get to see the vermeier survivor
once for three minutes ilium is where
the decision started taking form but
even then it was just a few short
interactions and that was it similar to
the council all of these will have more
impact in mass effect 3 so we'll talk
about them again later but this decision
to not showcase our choices just makes
this game feel so disconnected from the
rest of the series and as we just talked
about the main content already feels
disconnected as is thanks to the reapers
taking a back seat in the narrative mass
effect 2 really doesn't provide a lot of
reason to actually care about our
decisions making them not feel as
important as the previous game made them
out to be i want to move past this
content though is what i really want to
focus on is the planetary exploration or
lack thereof bioware revamped the
planetary exploration of mass effect 1
by completely removing it sort of all
you do now is go to planets and scan
them for resources from a pure gameplay
perspective this system has more
benefits than the previous one as the
resources are vital to upgrading your
equipment so on those merits alone i do
prefer this system but as a whole it's
just disappointing every now and then
when exploring a planet you'll find
what's called an anomaly which is a very
short mission that can take anywhere
from one to five minutes these usually
entail some random objective like
putting shields back online or just
navigating a swamp the one positive
though is that a lot of these places
look amazing even though they are
incredibly small the levels and sky
boxes are great i do wish that some of
these locations though were just a bit
bigger because the normandy itself is
bigger than some of these places also
i'm fairly certain you cannot revisit
them again so you only get to experience
these planets for the same amount of
time it takes to complete the mission
and that's it i just wish we could have
had the original system back because
exploring planets was fun yeah they
weren't great but at least we got to do
them i just don't think removing it
entirely instead of fixing the problem
was a good idea it makes the world feel
smaller as a result the removal of this
also makes me hate one of the dlcs in
this game more than usual the firewalker
dlc is probably the worst content in
this entire game it's all based around
this floating vehicle called the
hammerhead it was supposed to be a
better mako and traversal-wise it
absolutely is as the hammerhead has a
higher jump and a boost with it but
combat with this vehicle is insufferable
as all you have to do is aim near a
target and the lock-on missiles will
take care of the rest but that's of
course assuming you live long enough to
do that as the hammerhead dies extremely
quickly even on normal difficulty but
the main problem i have with them is the
worlds themselves you have to travel to
all these different planets for all
these missions and all of them are
completely unique and incredible to look
at and it makes me wonder what would
have happened if they had put some of
this time into the planets themselves i
will recognize that time constraints may
have played a role in this but i have
found no articles to claim this so it
leads me to believe that the removal of
exploration was planned early on it just
sucks that the great planets in this
game are held behind these missions and
these missions aren't even that good
either most of it revolves around
picking up items and then leaving you
can complete this entire dlc in about 30
minutes the ending was at least somewhat
interesting as the data that we've been
collecting belonged to a dr oloy who was
possibly indoctrinated by the reapers as
he was caught sending their research to
the geth there's also this prothean orb
at the dig site but of course nothing
actually happens as all the data we sent
to cerberus is going to take years to
survey so we're not going to learn
anything from this orb anytime soon
making the entire dlc completely
worthless at least the next one isn't
that bad though a rival is a dlc
revolving around another group of
researchers and another reaper artifact
can't imagine this will go well we are
first tasked with saving this doctor who
is being held at a batarian prison the
batarians are trying to interrogate her
so that she can reveal the location of
their main base after rescuing dr kenson
she reveals to us that the reason she
was being held prisoner was that her
group was trying to blow up a batarian
mass relay destroying one of these is
unheard of so far in the series so there
has to be a good reason for doing so
according to the doctor she states that
this mass relay what they call the alpha
relay is how the reapers will travel to
the other mass relays allowing them to
take down all sections of the galaxy at
once dr kensin believes destroying the
mass relay will stop them from doing so
in game the concept of mass relays is
misunderstood because the game allows us
to travel between any relay we want in
universe though there are primary and
secondary mass relays primary mass
relays allow people to travel thousands
of light years in a split second but can
only go to another relay often called
its partner secondary mass relays
provide less distance only a couple
hundred light years instead of a
thousand but we can use any of the mass
relays it touches within its range the
alpha relay is a combination of both by
tweaking its controls a bit you're
allowed to travel to any of the other
mass relays even if they're thousands of
light years away this is why dr kensing
wants to destroy it but doing so would
also destroy any life within its range
thankfully the system is remote but
three hundred thousand batterians live
on the planet we just rescued dr kenson
from so lots of people will die
regardless their plan was to launch a
giant asteroid into the mass relay which
they assume would be enough force to rip
it wide open the question still remains
though how do they know about the reaper
invasion well they have a reaper
artifact they call object rose just
sitting there in the middle of the
facility when dr kenson touched it
similar to that beacon on eden prime she
saw visions of a reaper invasion and
knew that the relay needed to be
destroyed despite saying only a few
minutes ago that she and the crew were
careful with the artifacts she ends up
betraying shepard confirming that the
crew was being indoctrinated as a result
though they knock out shepard and try to
keep him sedated until the reaper
invasion has begun clearly that isn't
going to work and now shepard has to go
to the facility alone and stop the
invasion himself during this whole
counter there's been a timer that's been
slowly ticking down and after getting
knocked out again shepard now has 30
minutes before the reaper invasion
starts dr kensin realizes her only
option is to blow up the asteroid before
it hits the mass really but because
shepard is shepard he stops that as well
just before leaving the asteroid though
shepard gets a visit from harbinger they
exchange in verbal blows for a bit
before shepard breaks out into this
weird speech about fighting until the
end and never giving up because that's
what humans do weird time to preach
about this but sure i'll go with it
shepard then gets picked up at the
normandy and the asteroid hits the mass
relay delaying the reaper invasion but
also denying three hundred 000 batarians
the chance of continued existence this
will and should have damage consequences
but and i'm starting to sound like a
broken record here none of that will be
seen until mass effect 3 and even then
i'm fairly certain it's just a few
dialogue changes also in case you're
wondering what happens when the timer
runs out bioware did plan for this
[Music]
despite it looking like a vision of the
future this is really what happened
after the timer hit zero and we can see
that the reapers killed everyone as
extra content arrival wasn't too bad its
first half was rather boring but it
started to pick up speed towards the end
which was nice but this story structure
was replicated in the next dlc project
overlord as soon as we start the dlc
we're flown into a different planet and
on the planet is a cerberus research
base everyone on the station has been
killed as geth have overrun the facility
while i don't mind it that much this
recycled plot of people toying with geth
or reaper artifacts because they think
they're different from everyone is
getting a little played out the only
member of the crew who's alive is archer
who says that their vi went rogue i
understand how important this conflict
between organic and synthetic life is in
this game but i really don't think we
need to rehash the same scenario a dozen
times to its credit how this happened
was at least different archer's brother
david is a genius due to his autism he
was able to mimic the geth language at
one point allowing him to communicate
with them archer figured that by
interfacing a human mind with a vi they
could control the geth and their guinea
pig for this test was going to be david
i think the main issue with this dlc is
the pacing it took roughly 90 minutes to
complete all the content but it wasn't
until the last 10 that the story
actually started taking shape everything
else before that while technically
necessary for the plot to progress was
really just busy work created to extend
the dlc's runtime all you do before this
is just travel to these gorgeous
environments and just hit a couple
buttons and fight a lot of death once we
do make it to david though we can see
how traumatizing these tests were for
him david is strung up and not only has
two giant tubes going into his mouth but
various other devices that are piercing
his skin it looks pretty awful we're
also given the choice of freeing him or
letting him stay like this both of which
are shown
you get the point already mass effect 3.
overall these past dlcs aren't too bad
but they just don't generate a lot of
excitement for me i left these dlcs
thinking oh okay well that was cool i
guess they just kind of existed they
weren't good or bad just middle of the
road i like the attempt at trying to
create a new plot for the player to
uncover but it's just the same scenarios
that we've seen a hundreds of times
already many of mass effect 1's side
quests at least the ones that were on
the planets ended in the same way so
it's hard to feel excited about the
fifth geth invasion or the fourth reaper
indoctrination i can maybe see these
being created as a way to show how much
of a threat the geth and reaper are and
how organic life will always be doomed
to repeat itself no matter what happens
but i don't need dlcs to tell me that
all you have to do is just play the game
indoctrination and geth have practically
become a buzzword at this point but i'm
surprised no one on illium is using it
for their marketing schemes reapers
indoctrinating researchers geth
attacking another colony filled with a
bunch of red arrows and circles like
it's a youtube thumbnail like yeah no
[ __ ] they've been doing that since the
series started but i guess this ended up
having its benefits a large group of
terrible content makes the one time it
actually is good stand out more and
layer of the shadow broker is that
content layer of the shadow broker is
easily the best dlc in this game as not
only is there no geth or reapers
involved at all but it also involves
liara attempting to kill the shadow
broker now that is a great sales pitch
to actually start the dlc we must meet
with liara first who we can see has
taken after her mother matriarch benezia
as she says the same line she said when
we fought her liara has been using her
time since mass effect 1 wisely and has
become a very well respected information
broker we also talked a bit earlier
about how she was paid by cerberus to
retrieve shepard's body before the
shadow broker gave it to the collectors
she also lost ferin during that job and
has vowed to stop the shadow broker ever
since thanks to the elusive men though
were able to give liara a bit of
information that could help her catch
him before we join liara on this
adventure she has a few jobs for us
something major it's just connecting
data points and trying to find someone
called the observer until we realize
that nick saris her assistant is the
observer and was likely going to take
liar out for the shadow broker after we
help liar she tells us to meet her at
her apartment later as she needs time to
look over the information but by the
time we arrived though things have gone
wrong apparently liar was almost
assassinated in her home there's already
a squad of police here who set up a
crime scene in order to find out what
happened their leader though stands out
for the rest and this is because
television is a spectre this is the
first time we've seen a spectre in this
game as the last ones we saw were
nihilus and sarin we end up working
together with tele to solve the crime
and honestly i was very excited about
this i was really hoping she would have
been a part of the squad as a temporary
companion as we haven't been able to
team up with a spectre before it would
have been a nice change to the gameplay
as shepherd is now on equal footing with
someone for once tele needs our help
figuring out what happened so we look
around her apartment and we can examine
a few of the art pieces she has on
display like shepard's armor seems like
everyone in the galaxy is more worried
about shepard's armor than shepard
himself we can also see that liara
hasn't let the business change her as
she is still the over-obsessed person we
know from mass effect 1 as she has
various prothean sculptures and even a
painting of islos once shepard touches
the picture of the normandy the picture
changes to a prothean dig site which
looks to be the same one we found her in
last game this was a clue given to
shepard by liara as she is hinting at
the prothean sculptures in the room upon
touching one of them a device pops out
that houses a recording of liara and her
contact ciquette apparently siquette was
able to narrow down the location of the
shadow broker so she left to go meet him
in his office in person shepard and help
make it to the office but just a bit too
late as the whole office was bombed tele
and shepard split up before meeting in
the middle and i gotta be honest i did
not see this coming tala is not only
working for the shadow broker but she
also broke into liar's apartment she had
her true motivations that shepard could
give her all the information she needed
as she didn't get a chance to kill lyara
the first time i think it was so blinded
by the fact that we were actually
working with another spectre and
possibly going to be on the same squad
that i didn't see the betrayal coming
looking back on it though it is a bit
fishy that a spectre was working with
the police on what seemed to be a
routine break-in but i hadn't considered
that at the time the crew then chased
tele through the building before getting
into a car chase which is another thing
i didn't expect to happen in the dlc we
have to avoid a lot of cars during this
chase and hearing lyra get more and more
agitated during this really makes it
worth it
she's got reinforcements
what kind of guns does this thing have
it's a taxi it has a fair meter
wonderful truck i know truck i know
there we go
you're enjoying this
layer of the shadow broker is really
good at just letting loose and getting
out as much personality as possible a
lot of the main content is very heroic
shepard whether paragon or renegade is
still a hero and acts like one since the
dlc doesn't focus on major threats of
the galaxy it allows the characters to
let their hair down a bit and just be
witty with each other shepard catches up
to tella but ends up taking a hostage
you can comply with her but i prefer to
use the speech check as this is one of
the few times the paragon speech ends up
dipping into the renegade a bit shepard
literally tells tella that he had
sacrificed countless human lives to save
the council and brought the rachni back
to the galaxy so one human woman is
nothing to him clearly shepherd was
bluffing in a sense as he wasn't going
to shoot the woman because she means
nothing but it was really to give liara
enough time to chuck a table at her
shepherd and liara then have to fight
tella and whether intentional or not
this fight really showcases how far liar
has come as a biotic she has this
ability called stasis which freezes and
knocks the opponent down even if you
upgrade the ability just once the
cooldown is so fast that you can
literally stun loctella for the whole
fight yeah she was still difficult due
to her health but she barely got the
opportunity to attack this may have also
been combined with a lot of the other
biotic upgrades i researched which were
increased damage and cooldown speeds but
with liar's help we were easily able to
defeat her before tala dies though she
says that the reason she was working
with the shadow broker was because his
info saved the council a few times so if
he needs a few people to disappear she
will gladly pay him back for his help
this is an understandable and realistic
goal like many of the antagonistic
figures in this game they have
reasonable goals but their methods are a
bit gruesome as a spectre it's her job
to enact justice and save the council
when necessary so the end result was
good but the means were the issue she
also says that shepard is just as bad as
her as he works for cerberus people
getting mad at shepard overjoining
cerberus is this game's version of the
council not listening to his claims
about the reapers it seems like shepard
can never catch a break over this stuff
and to an extent they are right he is
working for an extremist organization
but he has to or nothing else would get
done since no one even believes the
reapers exist in the first place it's
really hard for shepard to justify his
actions for joining when majority of the
galaxy doesn't even believe they exist
so to many he just looks like an
extremist which really starts to piss
you off after a while and i feel like
this was the intended purpose with tala
dead though she's able to get the data
she needed and now knows the location of
the shadow broker the shadow broker and
his ship orbit around a planet called
hagalos its climate and weather are
extremely dangerous but by following the
sunset he is able to be completely
undetectable which is perfect for
someone who hides their identity it's
also here where we can see the
production value really ramp up as the
skybox and level design are top notch
it's a really beautiful place to look at
even though we are thousands of miles in
the air and could probably fall off if
the wind was just a bit too strong
similar to the car chase a lot of the
witty humor comes out during this
encounter especially when shepard [ __ ]
is about the good old days when you were
able to use omni gel to hack things
instead of using tech programs which is
referencing the previous games where you
could do just that this dlc really is
one for the fans liar was one of the
most unique characters in mass effect 1
and having an entire dlc dedicated to
her was a wonderful experience i also
brought garris and talia along when i
could so it can really feel like the
good old days before the reapers made
themselves known liara and shepard find
farron but before we can free him we
have to meet the shadow broker himself
and he's
well he's something that's for sure the
shadow broker is a part of a species of
beings called the yag the odd grew up on
a planet called parnak the og have eight
eyes which give them enhanced vision
allowing them to detect body language
perfectly making it hard for them to be
lied in front of the og were discovered
around 2125 by the council but when it
was clear to the yogg that they didn't
come to their home world as their new
servants they attacked them because of
this hostility parnak is off limits by
order of the council which is why any
yag haven't been seen since as you would
expect there's only one way this is
going to end but the game purposely
knocks out your other companion so you
and liara have to fight him together
poor garris first a gunship now a table
what's next before the fight though the
shadow broker may comment on your
companion you bring as he refers to him
as archangel instead of garrus just goes
to show that the shadow broker truly
knows all the fight with the shadow
broker is similar to other large boss
fights in the other games where the
player does the exact same thing which
in this case is shooting him and then
punching him once his shield is up but
the added layers of difficulty after
each phase are nice as to make it not
seem tedious the room also has limited
space and cover so trying to kill him
before he reaches you can prove
difficult due to how he was defeated
though the ship suffered a momentary
blackout and some of the communications
dropped all the operatives he works with
were awaiting confirmation to make sure
everything is all right liar then takes
the opportunity to talk with some of the
operatives and since the shadow broker
never actually used his real voice
everyone was none the wiser and liar has
become the new shadow broker her story
really couldn't have gone any other way
since we've met her she's been obsessed
with research and information which is
why she became a respected information
broker and now she's the galaxy's best
information broker and has all the info
in the world liara does break down a bit
though as she has been searching for
farin and shepard for two years and not
only does she have both of them back but
the information she obtained could help
the war against the reapers this was
likely eating away at her for a while as
in mass effect 1 she helped but she
definitely wasn't the strongest ally on
our team and now in mass effect 2
despite knowing of the reaper threat she
was hopeless without shepard in his
leadership so she just used her limited
time to get a new job knowing that the
reapers could wipe them out at any point
but now she can pay shepard back for all
his help and this whole talk between the
two is just really sweet while this may
seem like the end the game isn't done
with the content as now that liara is in
control of the ship we can come and go
as we please and are able to use her
resources to our advantage the ship has
the regular upgrade stations like the
normandy but there is also an advanced
training section where we can respect
our companion stats a scanner that gives
shepard the location of planets with a
lot of specific resources which help
with the aforementioned upgrades and
research and you can also come back
every now and then and get deliveries
and even send out a random squad of
people to do missions for you it's a
toss-up on whether or not it succeeds
but if you do you can earn more credits
from it but by far the best part is
reading the notes of our companions and
other notable people in the game and the
video archive these provide incredible
insight into the shadow broker's plans
give us updates on our crew and allow us
to learn some of the funniest details
about the people of mass effect the
video archive isn't as interesting as
the notes but we do get to see some
incredible videos like that reporter we
knocked out get punched again by a
krogan and evolus as well as a few
videos showing our companions honestly
the rewards alone are more than enough
reason to finish this dlc i must have
spent 40 minutes going through all the
content and it was an absolute treat
layer of the shadow broker really is the
gift that keeps on giving from its
premise to its gameplay to its rewards
there wasn't a single low point at all
in the entire dlc the story of liara and
her character arc was a welcome addition
to the content and being able to just
enjoy a mission that doesn't have to do
with the reapers is always a nice change
of pace as i said it's easily the best
dlc in the game and it is one i
absolutely recommend you play after what
has felt like a lifetime we have finally
made it to the final mission since we
just spent the past hour and a half
talking about the rest of the game let
me quickly just give you a recap of what
we did in those collectors missions if
you remember the collectors are
abducting human colonies and the elusive
man is hiring shepard to put together a
team and stop them during the
collector's missions we uncover that the
collectors are working for the reapers
and are also the long lost protheans
their leader is harbinger a reaper who
is manipulating a collector general and
can use his powerful abilities to assume
direct control of any collector on the
battlefield later we learned that the
collector homeworld is not only
accessible through the omega 4 relay but
also in the middle of the galaxy using
an iff for identify friend foe system
the collectors are able to travel back
and forth without any problems shepard
and the crew then investigate a derelict
reaper where they find the iff and
legion which leads us to where we left
off this is technically the point of no
return but it's actually before you
start the reaper iff mission itself
after you find the device edie will plug
into the normandy and since the normandy
needs time to sync with it joker and
edie urged the crew to take the cerberus
shuttle this may have inadvertently
saved their lives as right after this
happens the collector ship arrives and
abducts the crew the iff was actually
transmitting the normandy signal to the
collectors allowing them to know where
they were at any point we get the chance
to play as joker momentarily and with
the help of edie we managed to not get
caught by the collectors joker once
again is present for one of the best
lines in the game but it's edie saying
at this time rather than him
now you must reactivate the primary
drive in engineering ah you want me to
go crawling through the ducts again i
enjoy the sight of humans on their knees
that is a joke right joker gets the word
out to the rest of the crew and now
shepard can decide what to do from here
earlier i said the point of no return
starts before the iff and that's because
we're now on a time limit every mission
or so some of the crew will die until
you reach four missions and everyone but
dr shakwas is dead we're only allowed to
do one mission assuming you want to get
the best ending which is usually
reserved for legion's loyalty mission
although it is possible to do this
before edie finishes the iff once you
leave to find the crew we are now in the
final mission of the game the infamous
suicide mission many choices we make in
this series create branching pathways
some players go down one path others go
down another the suicide mission can
create the most amount of branching
paths in the whole series it is entirely
possible to get every single companion
killed during this mission that's why
knowing your crew and getting their
loyalty is so important it's possible
for a companion to live without loyalty
but getting it will ensure that they
have a much higher chance of surviving
this mission is not going to be some
heroic story where all the crew make it
out alive and defeat the bad guy i mean
yeah it is possible to do but it's not
guaranteed and the game will not hold
your hand during this at all in fact i
would argue the game is purposely trying
to make you fail firstly there's a
chance some of your crew dies before you
even get to the ship all the crew on the
normandy have been giving you upgrades
for the ship like better shielding
better guns etc if specific upgrades
aren't purchased some of the crew can
die right after this you are tasked with
picking someone to go through the vents
of the collector ship so they can open
some of the doors on the other side not
knowing what to expect you may obviously
look towards your companions for their
thoughts jacob perks up and says that he
would be a great pick if you pick jacob
he will die later when inside the base
you'll need to choose a biotic expert
miranda says that she can do it
technically she can but her shield will
start to fail at the last moment getting
the other squadmate you brought along
killed the game is actively trying to
make you fail at every single point
pretty much for all the options you're
given if you either choose the wrong
person or choose the right one but
they're not loyal that person will die
this is not only important for the game
but the series as a whole mass effect 2
allows you to keep playing after the
final mission allowing you to finish up
some of the content you may have not
completed yet if any of that content is
done after the mission any crew that die
can never be selected again and all
those companions make an appearance in
mass effect 3 so having them die here
means that they'll be replaced by
someone else later the outcome of this
mission can change the entire
playthrough just from one decision it's
incredible and it's still my favorite
mission in the trilogy despite how
difficult it seems though it's honestly
not as bad as you think you need to pick
a biotic expert tech expert and two fire
team leaders if you've been playing with
your companions and doing their loyalty
missions then you should already know
who belongs where garrus is a great pick
for both fire team squads kasumi tali
and legion are great tech experts and
jack and samara are great biotic experts
not only do the loyalty missions allow
you to gain more insight on how a
companion plays during combat but that
knowledge can be transferred over to
this decision if you didn't do kasumi's
loyalty mission or never used her on
your team you might not realize she's a
viable option for the tech expert
position the best thing about this
mission though is that it was exactly
what i talked about when we discussed
vermeier i brought up other choice
between ashley and kate and was fine but
if you didn't like one or both of them
then it was a wasted opportunity if you
didn't like ashley there was no
emotional impact involving your choice
in fact you may have been happy that she
was gone now not only can a companion
die because of your choices but other
companions may get caught in the
crossfire as a result the suicide
mission is intense and stressful and the
difficulty reflects that by making the
player genuinely feel like they might
not make it out of here with everyone
alive one thing i will commend bioware
for though is that they make it equally
as difficult to kill everyone as it is
to save everyone doing the loyalty
missions pretty much guarantees a large
part of the crew will make it out alive
and i highly doubt most players didn't
do these unless they're purposely going
for an evil playthrough furthermore
there is a secret third ending to this
mission if you manage to get to the
final part with less than two companions
the shepherd will sacrifice himself and
die giving you the worst possible ending
to do a proper evil playthrough that is
good enough to carry over into mass
effect 3 you'll need to have two of the
crew survive and getting that to work is
a pain in the ass at least for how i was
trying to do it as you know i've been
going through the games twice and i
wanted to do an evil playthrough to not
only show what happens to the choices in
game but also who replaces our dead crew
next game but since all of them cannot
be dead or we fail we need to save at
least two of them but it needs to be the
least important crew members on the team
as characters like tali and garris have
important roles in the next game
thankfully with the help of some guides
i narrowed it down to zaid and morinth
this creates the worst possible ending
as their contributions in mass effect 3
are the least important it was
surprisingly a lot harder than i thought
to make sure both of them lived while
the others died which really goes to
show you how a lot of this mission is
really out of your hands even if you are
trying to skew things in your preferred
favor you still might not come out on
top this entire mission is mostly
focused on combat is trying to add in
major story plots while the player is
worried if they accidentally kill the
companion would cause them to miss out
on some key info it's not until the
final part of the level where we get our
last bit of information on the reapers
the reason the collectors were abducting
humans from their colonies was because
of this the skeletal machine in front of
us is a human reaper when a colonist is
harvested in those pods that we saw the
crew in they're turned into juice for a
lack of a better word which is then
injected into the human reaper after
enough juice has been injected inside of
it it is ready to become a full reaper
given that it only goes down to the
chest area they aren't even close to
done with it yet we aren't sure why the
reapers do this but the only thing that
we can speculate on at the moment is
that it's their form of reproduction
they use the species they kill as fuel
to make another reaper i want to clarify
that the reaper wouldn't look like a
human as a final product reapers are
giant and way bigger than this human one
is this is likely just the inside of the
reaper the core if you will while the
outer shell is just a regular looking
reaper so it's not the fact that each
reaper looks like the race it used as
fuel but the core of each reaper looks
like the race it used as fuel with this
in mind if this happened to all the
races prior to this current cycle then
that would imply that the protheans were
not suitable subjects for a prothean
reaper if they were that would mean a
prothean reaper would exist but since
they were turned into the collectors
that means either something didn't work
or they just simply found a better use
for them seeing as we managed to find
this reaper in its earliest stage we
have a chance to stop it before it's
finished we shoot the large tubes that's
connected to causing them to explode and
remove its supply of juice once we break
the tubes we come to the final choice in
the game which is to save or destroy the
collector base just like we talked about
with all the choices in this game we
won't know until the next game what
actually happens once you make the
decision though the reaper wakes up and
we are now stuck in a boss fight the
final boss fight it's a tough fight but
nothing too difficult except when the
game bugs out and forces garrus to float
which is a bit weird but other than that
it was a nice way to end the game once
it's dead the crew is sent off the edge
and it is also possible for them to die
here as well assuming they're not loyal
but this is the last time any of the
crew can die during the mission as
shepard escapes the ship we can hear
harbinger monologuing before getting the
reveal which confirms that harbinger was
indeed a reaper and not a collector
after the crew escapes shepard gets one
last talk with the elusive man who is
either happy or upset depending on our
choice of the collector base and the
background also changes color again the
final cut scene of the game shows the
crew or lack thereof if they died as
well as the reapers finally making their
move on the milky way as we can see them
all immobilizing towards the galaxy
which leads directly into mass effect 3.
mass effect 2 is an amazing game and
still my favorite in the trilogy the
characters we made across these games
are the reason i still play this series
to this day and having a game centered
around a large group of characters would
easily make it my favorite mass effect 2
despite not having a large focus on the
reaper still manages to provide us with
some incredible information about their
history and make the player yearn for
more once they see that the final battle
is finally upon us several of mass
effect 2's companions ended up becoming
some of my favorites in the trilogy and
it was due to this game allowing us to
see into their lives and give us an
opportunity to learn more about them
making them feel unique not every
companion had an amazing story but the
good more than outweighed the bad in
this scenario it's the highest rated
game in the series and it's clear to see
why there's so much content to do
characters to meet and lore to uncover
all of which is wrapped up in one large
present that is this game it's not a
perfect game mind you it does have its
flaws but it's nowhere close to being
that bad that the entire game is brought
down with it however mass effect 2 shows
us that there is still more to come
while the game itself might be done with
its story mass effect as a series is not
over yet as the final battle is about to
begin and while i would love to talk to
you about it right now we'll have to
wait until mass effect 3 to do so
thank you for watching today and i hope
you enjoyed i have to stop telling
myself that there won't be enough to
write about with these games since this
video has easily passed the 2 hour mark
judging by the amount of pages i've
written i do plan to talk about mass
effect 3 and andromeda sometime soon but
i'm going to take a break for a bit i'm
planning something really special for
october that i cannot wait to share with
all of you it's still going to be the
same content as usual but the games for
october are going to be horror related
if you want to know more details i'll be
making a community post about it once we
get closer to october so make sure to
turn on those notifications for the
channel so you don't miss it regardless
like the video if you enjoyed and
subscribe if you're new as always thank
you to my returning viewers for coming
back to another video and with that take
care everyone goodbye
you